Thank you.
Before I get into my rambling spiel, though, because I just want to wait.
Hey, KW.
I'm just saying we're going to be here for five or ten minutes before I start rambling because I just want to wait.
Oh, KW's gone.
But they might be back.
Who knows?
I've never seen them before.
Or maybe I haven't.
I just don't remember.
I don't want to detract from somebody.
Another crazy dude with connections to the intelligence industry.
It just came out they were making threats.
Hey, Shane.
So, Shane, I'm going to start the main topic in about five or ten minutes.
I'm just rambling on about Science Bob right now.
I never had anything against Science Bob.
He seems pretty innocuous.
I'm from the North.
And people from, you know, and the rest of the country don't really understand that
people from New England and people from the South can butt heads a little bit.
Right?
There's a long shared history.
But, you know, I mean, the man apparently worked in...
Hey, Bark.
Bark, I'm going to start the main subject in about ten minutes.
I'm just rambling on about Science Bob.
Because sometimes people will come back later and they'll watch the first couple of minutes.
Or listen to the first couple of minutes.
And, you know, we had that crazy...
I'm not in UFO.
I don't know why I say we.
I've been like absorbed.
Like an amoeba absorbs things.
And I guess I've been absorbed a little bit into the UFO-X community.
I never felt like I was in UFO-X.
But we had that crazy stuff where those...
Those guys were...
Disclosure Tonight guys were making crazy...
But it seemed to me to be...
Hey, Melissa.
Crazy threats.
Hold on.
Someone's requesting.
I'll let anyone up.
Hey, Shane.
Talk to you.
So we had these people making these crazy threats.
Right?
Like what a lot of us thought were crazy threats.
Aimed towards Red Panda Coal and Tupacar.
And again, I'm not one of them.
Okay?
I'm not Tupacru.
I'm not UFO-X.
But it was very notable.
And so at the time, right, the feeling was like...
What are these screwballs doing?
You know, this isn't the Cold War.
And these guys aren't...
Hey, Marie.
These guys aren't...
You know, who knows what...
Who knows who serves whom?
Right?
But what they're doing does not, you know, does not deserve having people threaten their life.
It's just...
It was just crazy.
And, you know, we're all on that page, I think.
And that's one of the reasons to stop.
Because everyone came out and they're like, "What are you guys doing?
This is ridiculous.
Don't act like this."
So I had a lot of concerns, but it wasn't anything to do with me, right?
But I stand up and be counted.
I don't want to be a...
I don't want to observe someone else being put through something tough, you know?
So I made a statement in a couple spaces.
I posted things.
Not that my opinion matters, but I just don't want to be that guy who doesn't say anything when something that shouldn't happen is happening.
So then we had this thing with this guy.
I don't particularly like them.
I don't really know anything about them.
So I don't know enough to say I dislike them.
But that's my...
That's my sort of instinct.
My sort of instinctual reaction to the Cosmogenesis or Cosmosis.
Kelly Watson.
I don't even know her last name, but I just find her to be off-putting, to be honest.
And I found him to be kind of...
I just...
I found it off-putting when I was listening to...
I'm not the demographic.
So I listened to a few of their podcasts and moved on.
And then I saw something crazy.
I don't follow Science Bob, so I don't know why it was on my feed.
But I saw this crazy thing the other day saying, "If you even listen to anything, if you support, if you listen, if you let anything J. Christopher King says influence you, then you are the enemy."
And I was like, "Whoa.
That's about as anti-social as it gets."
And this guy who I thought was this mild-mannered southern gentleman was just making this crazy declaration.
You don't say that.
You listen to someone else and you're the enemy.
What the hell's going on here?
Right?
So I wanted to know, like, what is this guy being charged with?
Like, what did he do that was so serious that if a person even talks to him or listens to him, somebody would consider them to be the enemy?
So I asked.
Like, what crime has this guy been convicted of?
Like, what is the deal?
And I got back this...
Science Bob has never answered me before.
So he answered me.
Okay.
I don't really...
I don't post to him all the time.
It's been like, this is the third time, I think.
You know, you don't answer me twice.
I don't really want to post a third time.
But because of the situation, I said, okay, look, I don't...
I don't even know anything about this Jake Christopher King.
But somehow I'm lumped together with this group.
So I'm going to find out, like, why I would be the enemy if I listened to what he had to say about whatever's going on.
And, you know, I got back some...
The messages I got back from Science Bob were not...
He wasn't cursing.
But he wasn't being respectful.
And I felt that I was...
I was direct, but I wasn't disrespectful.
And so I don't tolerate that.
And I told him off.
To find out what was happening.
And it turns out that this guy...
I'm sure you all know, because you're all in UFOX or...
Most of you are adjacent to UFOX.
This guy was sending unsolicited nudes and trying to sleep with women who claimed they were in a vulnerable situation at the time.
Now, as far as the second part, it's none of my business who tries to sleep with whom.
And I don't think it's anyone else's business.
The first part...
This was something that started with the millennials, right?
Like, with the cell phones.
And, you know, I was an adult at that time.
And we were all like, what are you kids doing?
I was in my early 20s.
They were...
Maybe it started with people who were in their teens.
As soon as the...
You could send the pictures to the cell phone.
They started having all this trouble sending these unsolicited nudes to each other.
And, you know, the rest of us were like, what are you doing?
These are going to be on the internet forever.
People are going to have these pictures forever.
You're creating this massive vulnerability for yourselves.
And both male and female, by the way.
Because, right, it was from that beginning that the whole thing about this non-consensual pornographic sites on the internet...
Like, it became a big thing.
No one should be sending non-consensual nudes.
I'm just going to use the term nudes.
It dick pics, right?
But let's just say nudes.
Like, class it up a little bit.
But that goes for women, too.
Like, and not only beyond the non-consensual.
I don't think you should be sending consensual.
You're giving somebody a weapon.
Like, I guess that's...
You want to show your trust.
Everyone trusts someone in the moment.
But very few of us trust people over the long term.
And it's nice when we can.
But you're sending this to somebody who's, you know...
There's a 50% chance they're going to try to use it against you in the future.
Or they would be willing to.
So that's...
It's crazy.
And it's offensive.
And he shouldn't have done it.
And if it's against the law, where he is, then he should face whatever...
I don't know.
I don't...
They send people to jail for that.
That's crazy.
Society has so many problems.
But, whatever.
Okay?
So it comes...
It turns out...
I'll go on the topic in just a minute.
This just really upset me.
And I'm thinking about it.
And I just need to get it off my chest.
And if I talk to someone outside of UFOX or off of X about it...
It's too crazy for them to even understand.
Right?
So then it comes out.
A couple people come forward.
Courtney Manchizzi.
I'm not a UFOX person.
Don't...
I'm not...
I'm not disrespecting her.
I don't...
I don't remember...
Manchizzi or something.
And UFO Sarah, who...
I don't know her, but I've listened to her.
They come out and they say, hey, what...
You know the thing is, the person who's really shady is Bob.
And they start telling these stories.
And clearly from listening to the story, like I guess if you were in the moment or if you're inexperienced, you could...
You could...
You might take it a different way.
But to one of us, right, out of the moment, hearing those stories, this guy is clearly trying to gaslight and intimidate these women.
If what they're saying is true.
And I don't disbelieve it.
And so it turns out that these people, right, who are leading these groups, both the guy sending the nudes to women who say they didn't want them, right?
They shouldn't have been doing it anyhow.
And the boomers, right?
The boomers who are supposed to be like the responsible adults, not that we're not all adults, but you know, that's how they portray themselves.
It turns out that they've been contacting people who put out stories in the UFOX community, according to the testimony of these other two individuals.
And telling them things like you're going to get yourself killed talking about that.
Right?
And we're right back.
We are right back.
Where we were a year ago or six months ago.
With these boomers fixated on talking about violence.
Right?
And it's like, to people on the internet.
I don't want to talk about the 90s because I'm getting old too.
But you know, in the 90s, they would say you're weird.
They'd say you're crazy.
People might not talk to you.
They might call you a conspiracy theorist, right?
But they didn't have, you know, people going around threatening people who talked about UFOs.
Maybe if someone saw something classified and then have, you quote, men in black experience.
Like, I'm not saying that wasn't part of it.
But it wasn't UFO hobbyists.
Right?
It wasn't people just talking to other people about it.
They would just say you're crazy or weird.
You know, the thing about this is, though, is these people all claim to be connected to the government, the intelligence industry.
Right?
And what no one is focusing on about this is, it is the worst possible sign when a society, when a nation, begins to try to intimidate its own citizens.
And it's not just like, oh, this is a moral point.
It's not like, okay, you know, I'm from New England and, you know, we, this is our liberal morality and I'm not, I'm really politically neutral.
But it's bad news because when you intimidate and you try to, like, you can't just intimidate them, right?
You have to try to foster a culture where people can be intimidated by individuals in the government and the intelligence services who used to be in the intelligence services, etc., right?
You are creating weak and cowardly people.
Now, I'm not saying that the two individuals involved or anyone else who may be a victim of intimidation is weak and cowardly because they were a victim of intimidation.
What I'm saying is that when you create, in order to, for that tactic to be effective, you have to sow those seeds in the population, right?
At the end of the Cold War, which I'm sure most of you don't remember, but some of you do, right?
The Russians were so intimidated by their government that they were, they had learned laziness and learned helplessness.
They had been behaviorally conditioned by their government to be unable at that time.
Now, things have changed.
Time goes on.
But at that time, they had been behaviorally conditioned by their government to lack any initiative.
They were so afraid of the ramifications of doing something that was inappropriate that they didn't, like, when the wall fell, Americans were going over there, right?
When Americans were going, like, I knew people went over there, they didn't protest, but some did, right?
Like, Bill Clinton went over there and protested.
Americans would go over there and stage protests, and the Russians wouldn't know what to do, because they'd never seen a protest before.
And the Russian people didn't know what to do.
They would just go home, right?
Like, we would not necessarily have come out on top of that if the Russians had not spent 50, 60 years creating such an atmosphere of fear and intimidation that their own government intimidated the people so much that people became cowardly.
And I would not call Russians cowardly today.
I also wouldn't call them cowardly in a fight, right?
Like, there are some really strong, really tough Russian dudes who would just kill me.
They'd probably kill me, just hit me one time.
I'm not calling them cowardly, but they were cowardly.
They were conditioned to be cowardly towards their government, right?
And that, more than anything else, was what happened.
And when you do that, you create this same scenario.
And is that not what is happening now?
Is that not what is happening and what has been happening in our society since the fall of the Cold War, when they no longer needed, right, brave people?
They started conditioning the citizens to fear the government.
The government.
But when someone comes out and says, "I spent my whole life in service to this government," and it turns out that they are calling people and trying to intimidate them, right?
Because the people talking about UFOs, okay, they are a disgrace.
Those people are a disgrace to this country.
It doesn't matter what they think about their service.
Okay?
I mean, it's supposed to be, yeah, we're all supposed to thank people for their service, but that is a disgrace.
Trying to condition people, behaviorally conditioned American citizens to react in a cowardly manner.
We will end up in the trash pile of history.
Like, thank God that young people are less susceptible to that.
And I'm sorry if I'm driving people away.
I'm going to go back to the topic in just a minute.
I just, it is outrageous that this is continuing to happen.
And, you know, I've never been part of UFOX.
Again, in the '90s, this wasn't really a thing.
I don't know how often this happens, but it is a disgrace that people are doing that.
It is a disgrace that Science Bob said that to them.
It is a disgrace that Mike Disclosure, whoever it was, because I don't pay attention to them either, right?
Like, I, you know, this is like, I use the basic principle with UFOX that remote viewers use to avoid hitchhikers.
I don't want anything to see me seeing it.
Okay?
I don't want any of these guys to see me paying attention to them because I don't want any connection to them.
But that is just disgraceful.
And it's, people need to start paying attention and start saying something.
Right?
I mean, yeah, it is unfortunate and it is wrong that a man sent a pornographic image to a woman without her consent.
It is.
It is extremely, extremely problematic that people are intimidated to the extent that others are calling them and saying,
if you say this, someone's going to kill you and then they have to be intimidated by it.
And the fact that that is not taken as, as seriously or more seriously than someone receiving an unsolicited dick pic.
That's a big problem.
That's not just a community-wide problem.
That says something about our society.
That is extremely bad.
You, look, I've been close to death many times.
Right?
I had an accident and I almost died like five times and I'm not crying about it.
What I'm saying is, you learn.
Okay?
That you can, anything can take your life.
A spider, a cat.
Right?
A car is stepping the wrong way.
You don't know.
Right?
You cannot live like a coward and a society cannot condition its citizens to be cowards.
That's all I wanted to say.
I just had to get it off my, my chest because there are some people here who, who are involved in UFO exit.
That is completely unacceptable.
And I hope that everyone will feel the same way that no one should ever receive a call saying something like that.
Be gaslit and intimidated like that because they're talking about UFOs.
On the other hand, I don't support anyone talking about classified subjects.
I'm not, that's why I'm not part of UFOX.
Right?
Like I don't think anyone should be advocating for, agitating for, as an activist for the release of classified information about government technology and shit like that.
We need the government to protect us.
I know it doesn't feel like that.
It's because our government does such a good job that it doesn't feel like that.
But you ask the people of the Ukraine, the people of Iran, right?
Ask them how they feel about whether they need their government to protect them.
And I'm not saying one is right and one is wrong or not taking sides.
I'm just saying that that's the reality.
So we shouldn't be doing that.
We also definitely shouldn't be gaslighting and intimidating people who ask questions and shit like that.
Okay.
So, and I'm going to run a space on it, but I just haven't had a chance in like such a developing topic.
Um, and who knows?
I'm not saying anyone wants to hear my fucking opinions on subjects like that.
But sometimes you just gotta get it off your chest.
Right?
Uh, Intuitive Underground was right about everything.
Thank you all for showing up.
Uh, if Morgan was here, Morgan is not going to be here.
Um, or at least not until later.
He has a friend in town, I guess, something like that.
But he also said that he doesn't need to know that, um, that he's right about everything.
He already knew that.
So he made some sort of joke about it, which is, which was nice.
Um, so there have been like one of the reasons that one Morgan, now he did not come back and start running spaces because I asked him to.
That was his own thing.
I had asked him to come back one time, um, so that we could run a space, a feedback space on the Intuitive Underground material.
And he came back, but I was thinking about other things at the time, like, you know, you just get distracted in life.
Um, and so we didn't run that space.
Um, we ran another space instead.
Right.
And, uh, you know, hopefully, you know, he'll be around for other spaces, but who knows?
Like I said, the future is not guaranteed to any of us.
I don't even know if we're going to be here tomorrow.
We're definitely, I don't know if we're going to be on spaces.
That's, that's the reality.
That's not crazy or intimidating.
That's just what you have to understand about life.
Um, but hopefully you will.
And that's, that's what our plans are.
Um, but then I was thinking, you know, of a subject for tonight and I said, you know, we
didn't run that feedback space.
So that's a good thing to touch base on.
And one of the things that set me off, well, it didn't set me off, but I've talked in, in
previous, um, defining remote viewing spaces that we have, we have a cordial relationship
with, um, the remote viewer who's involved with that, those Astor RV projects with Dan
Waits, uh, who I call mid Dan.
Um, you can say it's because I'm catty because he's successful as an influencer, but I've
never tried to be an influencer, but I, he would always, he would, he was destined.
He was born to be a better influencer than I ever will be.
Um, I don't know if that's true about astrology, but it's definitely true about being an influencer.
So, and you know, I was talking about, uh, Josh and I was like, yeah, no, he's good guy.
I, I think I stopped.
And I said, I think, I guess like we're all, we all have good things about us, but I just
had this like foreboding in that moment and come to find out, um, that he and his team,
uh, second house, uh, yeah.
Yeah.
Second house remote viewing.
If you want to check them out, they're on YouTube.
Fair is fair.
Uh, have started their own streaming service.
There are streaming services in remote viewing.
The other remote viewers who are either not interested in streaming services or who aren't
successful at setting them up are very critical of the remote viewers who set up streaming services.
Um, generally speaking, the streaming services, um, that charge money are staffed by highly experienced remote viewers or involve highly experienced remote viewers.
I say staff because while it's represented as some sort of a cooperative in general, they all work for one guy.
So, uh, far site, everyone works for me.
And I believe with, um, let's see how the one, uh, future forecasting, I believe they all work for deck.
And he may have a couple of partners, but definitely like dad's is not one of the partners.
Uh, dad's is a contract employee.
I think that is too.
I think, I think everyone, but Dick and maybe one of those other guys.
Um, so second house, um, remote viewing has started their own streaming service, uh, $25 a month.
Um, I guess if you're looking for entertainment, um, remote viewing as entertainment and you've got the money, then, you know, why not?
Um, they're all very green.
They're all very new.
And so that's, I guess they inspire each other.
Like Dan's been in astrology five years and he makes a living at it.
You know, they've been in, in remote viewing for five years or less.
So, but they want to make a living at it.
It's come out that some of the other remote viewers aren't trained at all.
At all.
Um, completely self-taught, which is again, like let the market decide, but they're not leading with that.
Right.
They're not leading with their lack of experience and the lack of training.
I'm telling people that that's a concern.
So at the time I was kind of like, uh, I had a feeling for voting that I might, something might change my mind a little bit about Josh.
I still wish him well as a person I do.
And I have no, I'm no, I'm no, I'm no grievance against him.
I just, that leaves a real bad case because it's the argument we've made.
And I know it's an argument he's aware of.
I believe it's one I've made to him, but, um, but he had been drinking at the time, to be honest, but it wouldn't matter any out to him.
Right.
But the argument against that is, is that you are, people see that they see you as an authority.
And then they make judgments of about everybody and the field in general, based on your ability to fulfill your commitment to them.
So if you say you're a psychic and you're not that good at it, or you're new, you're not that experienced and you keep missing things.
Now, people are going to come away from that and say, yeah, you know, some people have a little bit of psychic ability, but it's not really that.
And that's, it's, they're going to have that impression for a long time.
This is the problem I have with mid-damp.
Um, you know, he represents himself as being an expert.
He makes predictions, uh, that contradict each other in my experience, based on my perceptions of his channel sometimes.
Um, and if you make a prediction that, you know, um, uh, that car will break down or it will keep running or the spaghetti I throw against the wall will stick or will fall off the wall.
If you make both predictions, then a week later or two weeks later, a month later, you can say, yeah, look, I predicted it.
I predicted the spaghetti would fall off the wall, right?
Uh, no, I had advocated to Morgan and Dan, um, Dan, um, Dan Mann from intuitive underground that they do something similar.
So I went like, like, um, full disclosure.
I had advocated to them that they start something along those lines.
We've been talking a couple of years ago about how they can get their message out.
They're not, I mean, saying they're not good at self-promotion is the understatement of the century.
They're the worst at self-promotion I've ever seen.
And that includes myself.
Um, and they really don't want to be perceived as, uh, culty or as scammers.
And I think there's a lack of comfort with technology involved as well.
And believe me, I understand how that feels.
Uh, I had suggested to them that perhaps they should do a low price alternative, right?
Or set the bar at the bottom.
We're like, we're far side prime is like 10 bucks, right?
Enough that people have some skin in the game enough that it can, can help them like relieve the tension of, of having to constantly look for more, right?
More income.
And I, I really thought at that time that, um, you know,
Oh, Shane, I'm sorry, dude.
I see you dropped down to the listener.
I, I, I, if you had something to talk about, I'm sorry that I just kept going.
Yeah.
Let me know if you want to come back up.
If you've got something you want to, um, if you want to say, you want to just chat and hang out.
Um, I'm just going to go through like a list of, what I'm basically doing right now is, is going to go through a list of feedback for some of these remote viewing tech targets for them.
I just, you know, full disclosure.
I did.
I wanted them to put on a newsletter.
I wanted them to start doing podcasts, uh, guests on podcasts, right?
I wanted them to, um, to offer something similar, like on Patreon.
And the reason is, is that they were really good at what they do.
They're really good at what they do now.
It doesn't mean they're all good all the time.
It means that together, right?
When they, when they put the session data together from four or five of them.
They are very good.
And they get, they do not get the respect in the RV community they deserve.
One of the reasons, one of the reasons is, I don't mean to disrespect.
I don't, one of them seems fixated on Reddit and like the Reddit remote viewing community is just the worst.
I'm sorry, but it's just true.
It is just, it is just the worst.
Um, also run by people who little to no remote viewing experience at all.
Um, who have a strong political ideology.
And I think we all know that Reddit is a psyop, right?
Like I, maybe not everyone here knows this, but you know, Reddit, the majority is like 75% of the posts are generated at one air force base.
Uh, and you know, generally speaking, Reddit is some kind of operation.
I don't know what type of operation.
I don't, that's not in my wheelhouse.
Uh, and I don't know why they would want to do that.
But I guess there's some reason for doing it because you know, 75% of posts again, come from like one, one air force base.
I should remember the name.
I don't, but that's how little I care about it.
Uh, so one of the members of intuitive underground has spent a lot of time on Reddit, trying to convince people of the validity of, of RV and the validity of their data.
Um, and that was never going to happen, uh, because they're not very political either, but they're definitely not in the far left politically.
Um, that that's a hundred percent certain.
So they put out, um, I'll give you an example.
They put out, uh, in 2024, they put out the, um, the next president, right?
Um, a report on, on roving who would win the presidency.
And I said, Trump, now you would think, and this is the same part.
We have this problem in astrology too, like 50%.
I mean, first of all, more than 50% of people should come to the conclusion, like should be able to identify the winner.
Not everyone because they're it's complicated and there's no, like they can't teach you the technique.
It's like, you've got to kind of figure out on your own, like what technique you think will indicate who will win a political in election as there's so much over the years.
And anyhow, um, more than 50, far more than 50% of astrologers out there, uh, predicted Trump was going to lose.
So, you know, you could take that as saying, well, astrology can't tell you, but the reality was it's not astrology.
It's the confirmation bias of the people using it, at least on Reddit, right?
The majority of people on Reddit in these RV groups seem to react very poorly to their forecast that Trump was going to win.
Um, including, uh, criticizing their ability as remote viewers and accusing them of political activism.
And that's not the case, regardless of what their politics may or may not be.
Um, that is what they saw.
Now, uh, there were some other, like future forecasting group also saw Trump win.
Okay.
So there were some groups that identified Trump as winning, but you know, you shouldn't have a large number of people who identify as remote viewers who aren't able to predict who's going to win the presidency.
But the thing with that though, again, is we don't know how, you know, a lot of these people were never trained at this point at all.
So you would have to first, um, identify, like you'd have to first go, go through and parse the individuals who were trained enough that you could have the expectation that they would, um, be able to, uh, see that target, right.
Beyond that target.
Um, so now that's okay.
So that's, there's some feedback there and you're like, well, and that's twice, by the way, they predicted the election twice.
Um, I don't remember if they did a forecast on Biden or not.
Uh, so you'd say, okay, well, um, just predicting a presidency.
Uh, that's not that big a deal.
Now there aren't the political ones are here.
And I know that's the one that everyone is least interested in.
Right.
But because it's on the page, I'm just going to go through the feedback for those.
And then, uh, cause that's the forecasts because they wanted to really focus on at that time.
They wanted to really focus on utility and a political forecast is something that has some, or at least in their estimation has some utility.
Um, but they're not political activists.
So they predicted Trump was going to win.
Now in, in February, 2022, um, they published a forecast, uh, the end of woke.
There are some individuals that work with them who are, who are political, who are very liberal, who knew that they were, um, they were using like the, the highest standards.
Um, for checking whether people are on target for vetting the data.
And so even those people who are highly liberal individuals were like, look, um, you know, they did everything they were supposed to do.
Like they were on target.
So they, uh, they did put out a forecast, the end of woke.
And that one, uh, I think also was very poorly received.
Um, but that was in February, 22.
And they did predict very, very succinctly and accurately, um, that woke was going to be shelved and it was going to be shelved by, um, people in power who no longer felt that it served the utility that it had in the past.
So as opposed to being a grassroots thing.
And if we're all being honest politics aside, that's exactly what happened.
Um, now there are some people who are interested in bringing that back.
Apparently science, Bob.
Um, but there's no, you know, I, I don't, I don't know.
I don't know.
I don't think they've run a session looking at, uh, whether we'll come back in my experience.
Um, just from studying history that they, these, these, um, I call them, uh, moral panics, but you can call them whatever you want.
They, they happen every 20 years.
So I would not predict that it'll be back, but I'm not a remote viewer and I'm not saying that, um, in their name.
So that was 2022 when no one believed that anything was going to change.
And we thought, you know, or most people thought like it was going to go on forever.
So this is one that might bother someone.
Um, but you know, it is something that they put out.
Uh, they did put out a forecast in August of 2021, uh, North American vaccination fallout.
Now this is something I've said directly to Morgan.
Um, they look specifically at the vaccination.
They didn't look at COVID.
And so my concern, and I'm not going to make this a whole space about this.
Um, my concern is that while there can very well be things in a injection.
That, you know, are, you know, beyond the, um, the antigen beyond the, in this case, the, the, the, the MRNA that manufactured the spike protein that specifically the spike protein.
All that other stuff that could be in there.
Like that's problematic in any injection, uh, especially when rushed to market.
However, the spike protein itself is the, is the pathogen.
All right.
So, um, I would have looked at that and said, now that I wasn't active with them at all in 2021.
I would have said, look, go back and look at the fallout from COVID as well, because, uh, the damage being done by COVID is being done by the spike protein.
And my concern about the vaccination is that it's causing all these spike proteins to be produced in someone's body more, more than you're going to get during the infection.
But I wasn't there.
Um, so their result, I think could be taken in the light of, could be apropos for both the vaccination and the infection.
Because one of the things, one of the purposes that having us divide, and this is not a political rant, having us divided as a society so starkly, right, is that you're able to hide things by playing people off against each other.
So the same, if you, if you're concerned about the aftereffects of the vaccination, the things that you're concerned about are the same things that people are concerned about with COVID.
So people concerned about blood clots after vaccination don't know because they've never paid any intention that people concerned about the fallout of COVID were focused on the same blood clots.
There was the same, um, fibrolytic, uh, there's like fibrolytic blood clots and that I, I have to write things down, but I don't have it written down, uh, today.
Um, so both sides were like, you know, this is one thing that this is caused by COVID.
The other one thinks this is caused by the vaccine and both thing and the others, you know, are trying to hide it or something.
When in fact, they were both, in my opinion, uh, deceived.
Anyhow.
So one of the things that came up in their, in their, um, the session work is that there would be a kind of dialysis because they looked at the cure and they came up with, there would be a kind of dialysis.
That would be the cure, um, for the, any damage that you might, uh, receive from the, um, the vaccination because they did see it being, um, something really bad for people's health over the longterm.
Right.
And their website is intuitive underground.com.
You can read the full report yourself.
You don't need me to read it to you.
Um, but they did see that the solution would be a, um, a dialysis.
And that, uh, is something that's happening right now in Japan.
So as a guy named Kevin McKiernan, um, who invented a certain type of dialysis, um, that rids your body of all the spike proteins and everything, I guess, associated pathogenic associated with COVID or the vaccine.
Right.
So he's looking at both of them, which is an important point.
Uh, that has been imitated.
Like right now it costs you like $25,000.
You're going to fly over to Japan.
You're going to get a hotel room.
You're going to go through this pretty gruesome dialysis.
Um, there are companies that do something similar in Dubai for like 30 grand.
It's not the same though.
It's not the same protocol.
There are companies that offer like a $1,000 solution in the U S but this is happening.
There was no one, I mean, I pay pretty close attention, but I'm not perfect.
So maybe there was someone else, but to the best of my knowledge, there was nobody else in 2021 who talked about people inevitably needing this dialysis and describe this dialysis to deal with a long COVID or fallout, you know, getting sick.
So getting sick, those people who do get sick from the vaccine.
So those are three examples of forecast they made, which didn't, um, didn't work out well for them.
Um, people particularly because they were advertising them on Reddit reacted poorly, accused them of being activists and ignored them.
And now, um, people with a far less experience and a track record that's not even close to as good are dominating the remote viewing scene.
Um, at least the remote viewing streaming scene.
I don't want to offend buddy.
All right.
So they also have, um, a number of reports.
They did a deep mind probe, uh, expiration on Vladimir Putin.
Now, something that's interesting about the deep mind probe, um, that they did on Putin was that he was given like a certain period of time where he would wait to see what happened, uh, before he would escalate the war.
Now, what happened was Trump was elected.
Um, and that seems to have changed the calculus.
I'm not saying I'm not making any connection between him and the Russians.
I'm not, I'm not political, but I also don't have any of those assumptions that people have on either side of the political.
There's so much disinformation and misinformation that I don't take any of that at face value.
But, uh, they did, uh, identify, um, the Poseidon, right?
The underwater drone, um, that the Russians have, uh, that is capable of creating the tsunamis.
Now, people who listen to our spaces know that this is something that has come up repeatedly in a number of remote viewers' work.
Um, a device being used to set off, uh, a tsunami in the Atlantic ocean, if not other places, but specific in that case, I believe to the Atlantic.
Now that might be me.
It could be just a general ocean, but for some reason, I, I seem to remember Atlantic being involved.
It definitely was with, um, with other RV groups.
I'm just, I don't want to misquote Morgan.
Um, so when I, when I read that, I was talking to him and I said, oh, well, that's the Poseidon.
He's like, what, you know, like he clearly had no idea, had no idea.
Right.
So that was feedback that I was able to give him that yes, there is that device.
Uh, the Russians have built it.
They hadn't tested it at that time.
They have tested it now from what I understand.
Um, and it uses a large nuclear warhead to create a radioactive tsunami.
Now the reason you want to do that as a little digression, like we wouldn't want to do that.
But the reason a nation would want to do that is because the half-life of radioactive sodium, right?
The salt in the seawater, it's called salting.
And, uh, at one point in time, they were putting salt in warheads.
So, or some people were, supposedly we weren't doing it.
The Russians were doing it though.
So the purpose of that is that the, the half-life is 90 days as opposed to some of the other, um, fallout, um, elements, elements in fallout, uh, created by a regular nuclear explosion, which also only tends to happen when you hit the ground as opposed to an air burst.
So if you created a radioactive tsunami, um, those elements are going to last a lot longer.
And so it makes the area where the tsunami, um, uh, you know, where the water flows over the land, um, inhospitable.
The Russians have made public statements about this and they believe it will turn into a desert.
I don't know if that's true, but, uh, yeah, I mean, it very well could.
So in, um, in January of 2022, now this is the only one that I don't have any feedback for, except to say that this is something that's come up since that time in other remote viewers sessions.
They looked into, they did a report on spontaneous combustion and the conclusion that they came to was that spontaneous combustion, um, is a weapon.
It's, um, something that, um, is induced.
And, um, that when they looked at these incidents of spontaneous combustion, they saw somebody there observing the event.
It has come up, um, in other remote viewers data that such a, uh, process has been invented.
That's all I'll say about that.
Um, at that time in 2022, I think we all thought that spontaneous combustion was crazy.
Um, I don't think we necessarily think that anymore.
And I don't want to get into like the conspiracy theories about how you might do it.
But if you're a conspiracy theorist, um, you, you might, you might have some ideas about like what technology might be involved in doing something like that.
Um, they did a report on the purpose of human emotion and that touches the, um, that touches the other like main cannon material because they did a report on the light, right?
Right.
So that event after, um, death, when you see the tunnel of light, they did a report on, um, humanities intelligent design.
They did a, um, they did a report on, um, the origin of, uh, modern humanity and they did, um, the origin of Genesis one, one, the origins of the universe.
And it was those reports that, um, that led to Morgan and I were working together on Astro RV.
I had familiar with his website.
I've been, um, it had been suggested to me by another remote viewer, their website, intuitive underground.
I had read it.
I'd found it kind of disturbing.
I couldn't put my finger on it.
And when I went back a year and a half ago and rewrite it like this third time, maybe that's when it all clicked for me.
And I understood that all of those, all of those reports and those sessions were basically talking about the same thing.
And that's where we've really achieved the final level of feedback.
Um, those reports all touch on the concept of the reality overlay.
Right.
Which, um, anyone who's, who's followed us knows that was our first space.
And, um, at the time when we started talking about it, like we were disturbed.
I gotta say like, it was a process of discovery.
It's not like I haven't contributed anything because when I read that, I took what I knew.
It sparked, I don't want to keep repeating myself, but so for me, the intuitive underground material, those reports, um, were, um, a Rosetta stone that helped me access the meaning of information in esoteric texts.
So I had struggled with some information in 18th century esoteric texts and esoteric Christian texts and going back to the Gnostics.
I, the, um, the language was, um, it's difficult because people are, are describing things from their perspective with their level of technology.
So when they're describing these images, they're not really compatible with modern life.
Right.
I'll give you an example, not related to Morgan stuff, but just so you understand what I'm talking about.
Uh, H.P. Lovecraft drew a lot of his, um, a lot of his fiction from the theosophy movement.
The, a movement in the 18th century to translate esoteric Buddhist texts and bring that information back to the West.
Um, and those texts, um, they, they also studied clairvoyance.
So they, they, they started with those texts and they use their clairvoyance and they came up with like this giant corpus of information.
Um, H.P. Lovecraft was familiar with most of it.
And, um, he based a lot of his like monsters on things that were in that information, strangely enough, but it's true.
So what I think a lot of people don't understand is like when they're thinking about his, um, uh, Cthulhu, I think we've all, we've all heard of Cthulhu, right?
It's this giant with like bat wings and, uh, an octopus head, but I don't think what people, what people don't realize.
And I don't even think H.P. Lovecraft realized, right? That's an archetypal image.
But what we believe that is, is, um, hazmat gear.
We believe that is the archetypal memory of somebody interacting with, with beings wearing hazmat gear.
Now that sounds strange, but go back and imagine it.
Imagine someone like, obviously this wouldn't be yellow, like in our day, but picture that wearing the mask and out of the mask comes a number of tubes.
And those tubes are hanging down and connecting either with canisters on their back or canisters around their waist.
We believe that's where the, the archetypal image that is now or was remembered in H.P. Lovecraft's work as being like, you know, the, the elder gods.
It goes back to the archons and, um, in, um, their reports, you find that imagery, not of an octopus head, um, but you find the imagery of, um, ancient human beings, um, imprisoned.
And, uh, being experimented on by, um, individuals wearing what, you know, they would now look at as hazmat gear.
But prior to the modern understanding of what hazmat gear looks like, how would you describe it?
And if you were alive 2000 years ago, right, how would you describe it?
You would look at that gear and say, oh, it's sort of like an animal head, right?
There's nothing else in the lexicon of someone, uh, from 2000 years ago, the Middle East, 2000 years ago, that bears any resemblance at all.
The hazmat gear.
Uh, except the, you know, hypothetically some kind of animal head.
So that's the type of, um, Rosetta stone that the intuitive underground material provided.
I was able to go back and look at that.
And I was able to take going back to Gnosticism in the first century, like right around 50 years after the death of Jesus or the resurrection of Jesus.
And, um, you know, I was able to look at that, uh, the very first Gnostic book, the Apophrecon of John and come up with descriptions that like very clearly now, right.
Come across as somebody being experimented on when I first read it years ago, it didn't.
I, about a year ago, I, before we did our first, um, space, I showed Doomer daddy, the, um, those, uh, verses from the Apophrecon of John.
And he's like, wow, my God, that sounds so scientific it does to us right now with this understanding, but you know, like what we now talk about as when remote viewers look at that, they see some sort of metal cylinder or capsule.
Right.
In the Apophrecon of John, it says they were put into some kind of cave.
I don't know.
Is it is a hundred percent match?
No, but it clearly talks about the process.
That they underwent very, very clear that that's exactly what's happening in that scene.
Um, so when we first did our first, um, our first space with the doom room, or I guess it was our only space with the doom room.
Right.
Uh, they pushed back.
They, they pushed back against us.
Um, particularly me for being too, uh, doomery to doom and gloom and, and being too, um, uh, Gothic.
Uh, and if you, if you listen to the, if I could find it, I would, I would post it, but you know, if you, if you ever find it, if we ever find it, post it, you can hear that.
Um, they might deny it now, but it's true.
Um, and kind of tried a couple of times to switch the discussion to like a less disturbing topic.
Uh, since then they've gone through like a lot of growth on the subject.
Like the fringe, um, had some problems for awhile.
Um, not like personal problems and like problems with the idea, uh, and really wanted to grill me about, you know, could this be some kind of deception?
Which of course it could, but, uh, you know, I don't want to go through that, but if the deception is so big, big enough that it encompasses the whole world.
Then we're back at square one.
Right.
We live in a simulation at that point.
So, uh, when I was first talking to Morgan about this, like their concern with the experiment, uh, being conducted at base level reality, the generation of the, of the reality overlay, the, what we would call the simulation was, um, the, theirs was a spiritual.
And it was because the, the beings that became humanity, um, have souls.
They have, um, Morgan described it as a point, like a point of energy, like a spark, a divine spark.
I think is how the agents would have described it.
And those divine sparks were being harvested to, um, for power to run the experiment.
Now this is, this is something that's in the matrix, right?
Like I'm not, you know, um, the matrix movie was put out before that session was ever done.
Um, and the human beings were the batteries for the experiment.
Now that's what always are often comes up.
And it's, it's not just intuitive underground.
Since then I've, I found other remote viewers who've looked into the subject and it's all very predictable.
If anything, the remote viewing data from intuitive underground is more conservative than what other remote viewers see.
Um, I, you know, I, I, I could go through the list of this.
Some of them who like remote view the process of wouldn't being put into the, um, into the, uh, the tube, the tank.
And, um, it was definitely non-consensual.
It was definitely something done to prisoners.
And, um, apparently there was no anesthetic involved.
So that shows you like the type of, um, the reason why that might push back a little bit on, on having someone elaborating.
And having someone elaborate on this in, um, in a public space.
Right.
Cause you're talking about people being tortured.
Like horrifically tortured.
And the other Gothic thing about it is that, uh, once in the two, once in the tank, the individuals were changed in such a way that they're not going to be leaving the tank again.
So that's something that people, when they think about this subject, it's psychologically disturbing.
I didn't do a, um, I should have done a trigger warning.
I didn't do it because everyone here I've seen before.
So I'm pretty sure everyone is familiar with this.
Um, but I should have done a trigger warning saying, Hey, this could trigger you.
If you, if you are uncomfortable with horror themes, um, you, you, you shouldn't listen to what I'm about to say.
I did do that back then.
I need to get back from that practice.
Um, so what I zeroed in on when, when I was looking at those reports, the ones I just named, um, the origin of, of human emotions, the origin of, of modern humanity, intelligent design, the light.
Um, I zeroed in on the fact that the individuals involved were not just being used to power something.
Other experiments were being performed on them as well.
Um, and Morgan and I have generated most of our conjectures outside of a remote viewing space about this, but inside the remote viewing sessions, um, they discuss, uh, research being done on the cells, uh, regenerative, um, research being done on the cells, uh, itself.
And so, and again, trigger warning, if you're disturbed, but, uh, so what, what, what seemed to happen is that they're.
In this experiment there, um, their focus was on the brain.
And the rest of the body was just sort of there to support the brain.
So viewers saw tanks and some of those tanks had full people in them.
And some of them had partial people.
And some of them just had a brain.
And I think there were actually a couple that just had the soul in them.
And that's what really disturbed the viewers.
Um, they all had like very, and everyone who looks into it has like very negative reactions.
And as I pointed out in other spaces, everyone who remote views this topic or that I've ever heard of, you know, remote viewing this topic has some sort of crisis afterwards.
Um, yeah, a psychological crisis, post-traumatic stress, they quit remote viewing.
Um, they start like loudly denouncing their results and the results of anyone else who has the same results in the sessions.
Um, they blame, they said they don't want to publicize their material because they're afraid it's going to do psychological harm to people listening to it.
Um, but it's pretty obvious that they're the ones who are experiencing the psychological harm.
Uh, they get stagnant, stuck.
I know intuitive underground, right?
Like I'm not disrespecting them.
Like I've, I've been stuck like in my life, particularly since my accident.
Um, but they clearly are in that similar situation.
Like this is something that really is, is very consistent with remote viewing in depth.
Um, the, the origin of like the matrix reality overlay, uh, the light, the, um, the origin of human beings, et cetera.
Um, I can tell you like, uh, in the remote viewing community, one individual who, um, is often remarked about is Courtney Brown.
Uh, Courtney Brown does not add to, uh, seeing this material, um, but does like talk about the light.
He talks about all of it in the context of it happening on a, like at base level, like we're at base level.
Um, and he won't respond when people try to talk to him about the other part of it, like the matrix aspect, but he's clearly very disturbed around the subject.
Um, and you can see it in his eyes, like he gets visibly disturbed talking about it.
Um, even after all these years.
Uh, so when we, when we did this space a year ago, um, a year ago, this month, we still didn't have any feedback on human beings being used to generate simulations.
Um, at that point in time, like it was purely something that existed in Hollywood, right?
Like you can make the argument, look, you find it in ancient Gnostic texts.
You do, but you could, you, someone could make an argument.
You're misreading them.
You can say, look, I find them and you can find them in esoteric texts.
You do, including esoteric Buddhist texts, esoteric Christian texts.
You do.
You could say you find it, we're looking into Hinduism and Buddhism and the origin of reality.
You, Chan Votan came into our space one day and schooled us on the Mesoamerican connection and, and how you find it in the Mesoamerican tradition as well.
You can make all those arguments and people can rationalize and justify, uh, the, the psychological denial.
Um, because in the world around us, it was still science fiction, but what happened is, and let me get the other device.
Um, we don't want to be able to give you the actual name of the company, uh, a month or two after we did that space, I found, um, information online, uh, randomly about an Australian startup company, which was selling biological computers.
And at first I had been led to believe that they were, it was brain tissue from mice being used in the, or I had maybe led myself to believe it because I had heard some experiments that they were using brain tissue in mice with electronics, but I'd put it out of my mind.
I hadn't made the connection because I'm like everyone else.
It's a super disturbing subject.
Like I said, it took me two or three years to get to the point where I was capable of having the conversation about this with Morgan.
Okay.
Like I couldn't see it either.
It's, it's, we have something built into us.
It doesn't want to consider things like this.
Okay.
Uh, but it turns out that cortical labs, it's an Australian company.
And, um, last year or late 2024, they started marketing a computer, um, that is run not with silicon, uh, but with human brain tissue.
So there were experiments going back like five or 10 years where they started creating human brain organoids.
And we all said, Oh my God, you know, what if these little brains had consciousness, they were just keeping them in Petri dishes and shit.
And like, it's unethical.
Is it an unethical experiment?
Oh yeah.
Incredibly unethical experiment.
Should it be allowed to happen?
Absolutely not.
We live in an insane world where they can allow something like this to go on, but it was happening.
It wasn't, uh, until last year that we found out after we gave our space that they were selling computers.
Um, these $35,000 boxes, it's a white box.
And that's, I point that out specifically because in UFO abductions, you see a very similar box, but it's a black box.
And it's often referred to as the black box of Saturn where people in UFO abductions experience having their soul removed from their body and put into a black box.
Um, I don't think that it's their soul.
I think it's a digital avatar being removed and put into the black box, but I don't want to quibble about details.
Um, in this space as we're talking about feedback here and the feedback is after right.
10 years after they started the project and years after they wrote the reports and after Morgan and I finally worked out the details, we found out that an Australian company was producing.
Um, computers, um, running on human brain tissue, like 200,000 brain cells each, which is a small amount of brain tissue that fits on a chip.
Um, but the first thing they did with it was create a simulation and that original simulation was Pong.
They taught the brain to play Pong.
So like we can laugh and say, oh, well, they're playing Pong.
Ha ha ha. I mean, I wouldn't laugh about it, but I know other people have.
Um, but you know, it's not like us playing Pong, right?
Like you, I mean, I don't, most of you guys probably don't remember Pong, but you would look at this, right?
You have the thing in your hand.
It's a handheld game.
Um, I think it was on computers at one point now, but it was handheld when I was a kid.
So it was a handheld game, right?
And you're having the experience of like looking at an object and playing a game on the object, but that's not the experiments the brain cells have.
They don't have senses.
All right.
They are immersed in a simulation.
How they experienced that.
I don't know, but Pong is the world for those brain cells.
It is a simulation.
Since that time, the, um, the company Cortical Labs has trained those same computers to play Doom.
Now we've talked about this in other spaces.
The horrible irony of the fact that the second thing they trained them to do was to play a first person shooter game in hell.
So again, they don't have senses.
They don't have any sensory data outside of that game.
They are completely immersed in the simulation of Doom, however they experience it.
So the first thing people do when they create, um, computers in 2024, or yeah, that's what we believe it happened, right?
Who knows how long they've been running them for.
The first thing they do is create simulations.
I've had people ask me, um, around that time, they would ask me angrily in UFO experience groups.
I'm not an experience of myself, but I would join them to be supportive at that time.
And I would have people angrily ask me, well, why didn't they just use AI?
And I said, you know, first of all, whatever's going on outside the simulation, you can't assume they have AI, right?
Like just because we developed Silicon technology the way we've developed, it doesn't mean they would, right?
But people would often raise that, uh, objection.
Now the answer to that, why you would use brain cells is because, um,
brains teach themselves.
They don't have to be taught.
So AI, you have to condition it.
You have to expose it and train it on all kinds of data.
You don't have to do that.
The brain trains itself.
That's the advantage.
You can also store a lot more data in there.
Be honest.
You can store, store data on DNA.
And they're talking about replacing Silicon with DNA at some point for like hard drive storage as well.
So it's an all in one solution.
It's a better solution than Silicon, but people did raise that.
And I didn't, at that point, it was still science fiction to me.
Well, now we have the answer.
So the final feedback came today.
And the final feedback is, uh, Cortical Labs is building data centers now.
They are building a data center in Melbourne, Australia, and they are building a data center in Singapore.
And, um, without boring everyone by reading too much, um, instead of racks entirely with traditional servers.
Oh, Phil, instead of racks filled entirely with traditional servers.
Now you don't know why I don't read stories for me.
Um, these sites will hose, will house.
Let me slow down.
Let's see.
I'm getting agitated because it's, it's a disturbing subject.
Okay.
Um, instead of racks filled entirely with traditional servers, these sites will house the company's CL1 systems, which combine lab grown neurons with standard electronic components.
The aim is not to replace Silicon outright, but to explore whether living neural systems can compliment existing hardware in specific computing tasks.
So if you go into one of these data centers, instead of big racks of computers, they have big racks of little white boxes.
And inside those little white boxes, let's call them small pods, right?
Because there is liquid in those pods because this is living material.
So just like pods in the matrix kept a person alive, everything those pods in the matrix had to do, these little white boxes are doing for those brain cells.
They are feeding them, washing them.
Right.
Cause you got to wash brain cells.
Believe it or not.
Like when you're asleep, brain cells contract and your brain washes the spaces between the brain cells.
Like that is happening in these pods.
So if someone says to you pods aren't real, like the people who report seeing the stuff in visions and dreams and remote viewing are seeing something that doesn't exist.
You can now say it does exist, but right now they're small and they only contain small organoids, artificially created human brains that we don't know if they're conscious or not.
Because realistically, that's a question people ask.
Right.
Cause it is, it is brain tissue.
So realistically, these chips could very well be conscious in a sense and living in a simulation of a first person shooter in hell.
And now they are filling up warehouses with them all lined up rack after rack after rack linked together into one mainframe type scenario, right?
One server farm.
I'm not a computer person.
So if it sounds like I'm ignorant, I am linked together into one biological technological server farm.
That is exactly what the intuitive underground material says.
The only difference is that instead of small brains created on computer chips, they took political prisoners and stuff them into pods.
But otherwise it is exactly the same linked together, experiencing the same simulation.
So that is the final feedback.
When people often criticize, they have criticized in history, right?
They rounded up and killed off a lot of the Gnostics a few hundred years after it began, right?
So Gnosticism was in the mid first century.
People get confused about that.
And I think it means like 150, but that's not.
The first century was zero to 100.
So when they say in the first century, right, like it's very close to the life of Christ.
So Marcion, the first traceable Gnostic, although you could trace it to Simon Magus, Simon Magus lived 20 years after Jesus.
And there's a historical record of it.
Even if you argue there's no historical record of Jesus, there's certainly a historical record of Simon Magus.
They built a statue to him in Rome.
Marcion was a disciple of John the Apostle.
So he was writing still in the first century, a little more than 50 years after the death of Jesus.
And when you say, well, because people will also raise that, they will raise that objection.
And they'll say, oh, no one, none of Jesus's apostles, you know, could be alive 50 years later.
Well, actually, they were.
I mean, it's an uncomfortable fact for some, but they were like 15 and 16 years old at the time when Jesus was alive.
So they did live that long.
And John the Apostle did die at like, I think, 95 AD.
I'm not positive about that, but it was somewhere around there.
And that's, there's a historical record of his life.
Um, so, uh, a couple hundred years after that, right?
They, they rounded them all up.
Let's say 100, 200.
Yeah.
So in around 340, I think is when they rounded them all up and they burned all the 319 to 340, somewhere around there.
They burned all the Gnostic books.
And we only have them because some monks buried them in the desert.
We didn't even have them.
Like when my grandparents were born, they didn't exist.
I didn't have them.
They were only something that they had read about from reading.
People criticized them.
Uh, they went after the Cathars, the Bogomils, whenever Gnostic, um, the Manichaeans first and later, uh, Bogomils, Cathars.
Anytime a Gnostic group would find some scrap, some old book and start a religious community, they would branch out.
They become successful.
They would be crushed and destroyed.
Massacre.
All right.
I'm not taking away from the persecution of paganism.
Uh, sometimes I think, you know, it seems like that when the topic comes up, but when you want to get into like, you know, who were the people who were really like rounded up in mass, it was Gnostics.
Um, that's where the numbers come in.
So, uh, in the 1800s, when the theosophists were writing about this, uh, one guy was honest enough to sort of try to explain the simulation.
And all the other theosophists turned on him and got very upset because, um, the Buddhists had learned that there was a taboo around this information and they all kept it.
Um, they use code terms that that's why it's hard to decipher because people didn't want to be rounded up for, um, for promoting Gnosticism.
So they used, you know, intentionally vague or metaphorical language that you can only make sense of once you have, in my opinion, once you have the modern remote viewing perceptual data on the subject.
That's the Rosetta Stone.
So that's, we only had that, uh, uh, 10 years ago.
It's like this one group who started other remote viewers have done it.
They, I mean, I'm going to be awesome.
And I'm not saying this, you know, we have remote viewer here.
We have two remote viewers here, right?
The well-known remote viewers intentionally hide the data.
They do.
I've seen like a video during COVID of 30 or 40 of the most prominent remote viewers doing a zoom call because then they then put it online.
And they were asking, uh, one of the remote viewers who was famous for talking about the subject for a little while and then stopped and renounced it.
You know, why did you do it?
And he said, Oh, because I was getting crazy messages from people.
So like, I'm not saying there's no reason for them to feel like they shouldn't spread the information.
What I'm saying is that's, that's a decision that has been made over and over again.
Now, the one group who didn't make that decision at any point was intuitive underground.
No one pays any goddamn attention to them.
Right.
Uh, when they go online, they join the, um, uh, remote viewer group groups online, the discords and the web pages.
Uh, they are not given the respect they deserve.
They're not given the respect they deserve for their 15 years of experience.
Right.
They're not given the respect they deserve for their intense training.
And they are definitely not given the respect they deserve for the intuitive underground cannon, uh, uh, material, which is no other intuitive, no other remote viewing group on earth that I'm aware of.
Okay.
There could be someone I'm not aware of has anything like it has a 10 year project specifically aimed at investigating the nature of reality.
And although I listed off like 12, uh, forecasts and reports that they have put out, they have another hundred or 150 or reports worth of material that they lost heart before they put it out.
And I think that, you know, if Morgan was here, I wouldn't put it in those terms.
Right.
But I think that those of us who are here, like, no, you know, Morgan, he's a decent guy.
And we can understand why someone would lose heart in that situation.
When everyone else is trying to suppress this information, they're trying to put out and people are ignoring it.
And when they do come out, they talk about it on Reddit for some goddamn reason.
And then the people on Reddit just go batshit crazy.
Right.
Cause they're not even trained remote viewers.
They're just these, these randos with a political ideology who just beat down anyone who doesn't agree with their worldview.
Um, like these guys should be famous.
Like they're not like, it's like, uh, like, um, you know, like no, no one's going to write a thing about like, um, what well-rounded, uh, historical figures they are, but should they be historical figures?
Yes.
They absolutely should be historical figures.
Oh God.
I'm sorry.
I have a cat problem right now.
Um, for what they've done with this can of material and this material should be these, all of this material should be.
They have material on, um, a lot of people here are concerned about, uh, demons, non-human intelligence without form.
They have material on that, uh, aliens.
They certainly have material on aliens.
They, um, they just have a ton of stuff.
They have religious stuff because, um, you know, a number of their earlier members were religious.
And so they have information on the book of revelations, the bond of the covenant, which is the, um, the 144,000 people who escaped the destruction during the book of revelations period.
They have that, right?
Like this is super well-rounded stuff.
And their record is like, they hit the target.
And if they don't hit the target, it doesn't go in the report.
Right?
Like they, they agonize over every detail.
You're not going to find anything like it anywhere.
You're not going to find it with future forecasting.
You're not going to find it with far side prime.
Although both of those groups have an extensive library of information and some of it is very good.
You're not going to find it with second house.
Although they may hopefully produce some great information.
Although again, like, you know, the untrained viewers should get training.
Um, the, the untrained viewers in the group, I know they're not all untrained or partially trained or whatever.
Um, yeah.
So this is like the final, right?
Like if you, if we were going to say like, what, if we wanted feedback to show that these guys were on target with their project, what would that feedback be?
Well, we would have to prove pods are real.
Right?
They would have to put someone in a pod.
They have.
Just not in the sense we would imagine.
And, you know, something to get more gothic and more grim.
Let's just take it to the furthest, most gothic and grim extent we possibly can.
Let's get it over with.
Trigger warning for anyone who is easily disturbed by horror themes.
You do not want to listen.
Okay.
So the ultimately most disturbing part of it is not the idea that, uh, we are digital avatars.
We are dreams in the mind of, of sleeping individuals in a pod someplace who are never getting out of that pod while they live and whose souls charge that pod.
Like as a, as a horror story, that's a good one.
Um, and it's disturbing.
Like a good horror writer could make it like really disturbing.
But the real disturbing part is that when they look at this thing happening, right?
Like when remote viewers look into the subject, they see a real prison.
It's not a metaphor.
It could be a metaphor for something, but they consistently remote viewers see like a, a building.
Now intuitive underground has done a lot of work looking at that building.
And, um, it's a large building, but it is a building and the experiment is in the basement of a building.
Uh, I don't know.
It could be the biggest building in the world and there's not much going on in base level reality from the remote viewing details.
Uh, the process of creating the experiment wasn't too good with the local population, I guess, because remote viewers who look, say there's, there's no one there.
And at people who astral body travel and go, they say, there's no one there as well, except obviously whatever, whomever is running this experiment.
Um, yeah, but you got these tubes, these cylinders, these pods in this basement, like one of these servers, right?
Lined up one after the other, after the other.
Right.
So, um, we know what that looks like, and this is what that looks like.
The difference is, um, right.
They use people there, but remember the part I told you in the earlier, um, not every tube has a full body in it.
Right.
Some of them just have brains in them.
So when I touch back on what I brought to Morgan's attention when I read his reports, right?
First of all, there's no one getting out of the pods in the reports.
Second of all, they're doing, uh, he never emphasized the fact that remote viewers were seeing cellular regeneration, um, experiments.
Again, I, I, I, I'm not a remote viewer.
I have not looked at that target.
Even if I were a remote viewer, I can only speculate.
Um, but it's, it would be very understandable if, uh, oh, cloning is mentioned, I believe.
Um, but cellular regeneration, I think it's given precedence.
Like it, it's virtually the same thing.
Um, so I, I think it's close enough that, um, we could, you know, speculate they were doing something similar to what the Australians have done at cortical labs.
Um, the, the people were the, the original, but maybe not the, the, the last.
So other movers have seen this and there is some speculation that the people are being used to run machinery.
Uh, I know Courtney, um, Courtney Brown says that he claims that people are being, um, transformed into greys, uh, for warfighting purposes.
The greys are like Cybermen and Doctor Who or Daleks.
And, um, so like he knows, right?
Like no doubt in my mind, he knows this information.
He just, um, is too disturbed by the implications to like be forthright about it.
Um, so yeah, he's saying that the people are being turned into greys.
The greys are like Daleks.
The theme of war comes up, uh, comes up in all the RV data on the subject that this, you know, this experiment exists because there's some kind of war.
Like, so this experiment is, exists to promote a, a, a warfighting effort, right?
So it's like weapons technology type stuff.
Um, and you know, Morgan and I have had many discussions about things you could do, um, with this type of, uh, simulation.
And I often tell people like what the purpose of the simulation aspect of it is to develop emergent solutions to problems, right?
Like alloys, technology, all kinds of things like that, that, that may be applicable outside of a simulation as well.
So that's what we would do, right?
Like these human brain server farms at some point will be tasked to coming up with inventions of some kind, right?
So that's what we're going to do.
I think I'll write the final feedback.
I got dumped, but it's, it's just, it's just X.
That's how it works.
Oh, it's nice to see new people here.
See, my screen freezes up.
So I'm not able to say hello to new people.
And so people might feel like I'm not recognizing them.
But Morgan is here.
Hello, Morgan.
Sarah Beth.
Hello.
Edmo.
Tender.
A cross plus CG.
Yagmer.
And the people who were here before us.
And then, and untitled Melissa.
I mean, you're the core group, right?
Mark, like a, a duck, Sal, blue, Shane, Sadie.
I think Buddy dipped at some point.
Like this is not, let me be honest.
Buddy seems like a nice guy.
This is not his type of remote viewing.
He's experienced remote viewer, but this isn't his, isn't his.
Isn't his thing.
Um, but I've never talked to him about whether he's looked into this subject.
I've never seen session data from any remote viewer who's looked into this subject.
That's not compatible with all the others.
That's just, I'm just going to say that.
Right.
But some people don't want to look into it.
And it's, it's for the best thing for those people, because people have real problems when
they look into the subject.
They do.
Um, yeah.
So the server farms.
Hey, Morgan.
I don't know.
Give me a, an emoji.
How long you been here, dude?
Hi, 77 CC.
Um, did, did you hear about the server farms?
I don't see any emoji, but you know what?
My screen could be frozen again.
So I'm just going to repeat that one part.
Cause we have some new people here and I don't know how long they've been here.
So cortical labs, the company in Australia that created the computers that run off.
So look, you see it.
Okay.
Morgan knows.
So Morgan, they have server farms now, dude.
Uh, they have two, one in Melbourne and one in Singapore, and they're building more.
And instead of computer racks of computer technology, they have racks of the little boxes where
the brains are.
So little pods, right?
Because one of those computers is a little pod because it keeps the brain cells alive.
So it has biological functions.
Like it feeds them glucose.
It has a fluid in it.
It's a pod, but just, there's no person in it.
Just a brain.
And so you've got these server farms now that exist now today in real life, what we consider
to be real life in this reality, um, that are the fucking matrix.
And the only purpose that those little brains serve is running simulations.
So far Pong and doom that we know of.
Um, but that's what they're going to have them do.
Right.
And that, that is the final feedback unimaginable.
When the matrix came out, if you, if you were like a, a young person who took the matrix
seriously when it came out, or you tried to write articles about Gnosticism as the root
of the information in the matrix, people would scoff at you.
They'd call you a weirdo.
Um, they wouldn't believe anything you had to say.
Uh, when Morgan and I, they've been doing this for years.
And like we've talked about, like remote viewers have been sweeping the data under the rug for
years.
Right.
You know, they don't want the, um, they don't want to be treated the way people treat people
who talk about this and other reasons.
And they don't want to disturb people, et cetera.
Right.
And intuitive underground is the only group that I know of who has not swept the data under
the rug at all.
Okay.
Um, also the group that, as I pointed out, has the most accurate data.
I gave an example at the very beginning, Morgan.
I went through your reports.
I gave feedback on each of your forecasts and on most of your reports, uh, demonstrating,
you know, things like predicting the dialysis, sorry, dialysis for people with the spike proteins
in, in 2021.
Right.
Stuff like that.
Um, they had 2019, they ran a, uh, they did session work or they published a report based
on session work on the COVID pandemic, explaining the, like, you know, how it was created.
So like the, they're on target.
Right.
And I don't know of another group that has the same level of verification, um, and feedback
for the reports they put out.
Um, future forecasting has some good stuff, but they just, they'll talk about a fire and
then they'll wait till there's a fire and say, okay, that that's the fire.
Right.
And there was going to be a fire sooner or later.
It's not the same level of specificity, not the same level of, of verification and feedback.
Now we're talking about the ultimate case.
Right.
And no one can say remote viewers are viewing egregore.
Now, uh, a story that someone created that can't exist when they view, um, the simulation,
the reality overlay, they can't say it because it exists now.
Right.
We built it now.
Why?
Well, I always mentioned, um, Rick Sanchez's battery from Rick and Morty.
And people laugh at me.
Cause you know, I'm a 51 year old man talking about Rick and Morty, but everyone I know my
age loves Rick and Morty.
Oh, and people can say what they want.
Um, you know, in, in, in one Rick Sanchez, uh, built a simulation to power his, his battery
for his automobile.
So the same basic principles, the matrix, the same principle as the intuitive underground
cannon data, but made in a cartoon format.
Right.
And then each one of them builds a battery to support their own simulator, a simulation
to generate energy to support their own world.
So they got like four levels of the battery and we're at the very bottom level, but it,
but it simulation theory posits that as soon as a society gets to a certain level of technological
sophistication, they're going to build another simulation.
And so there would be a, a number of these simulations.
And that is also what the intuitive, well, intuitive underground, I think has similar data,
but like, that's something that the ancients and I think remote viewers see is that there
are different levels to reality.
And we just happen to be at the bottom level.
Um, part of it is, is awakening to who we are.
Like I talked about this with the AI, like when there are so many similarities to the way AI works
and a human being works, like, why would we build it now?
And like, this is the, this is the point when we are struggling to awaken and something that people
who study remote viewing know, and anyone who studies eschatology, prophecy, predictions,
new agers, et cetera, knows that, you know, predictive people see some sort of future crisis,
disaster calamity.
Um, Ed's men are, uh, Morgan's mentor, Ed Dames called it the kill shot.
Um, and ascribed to the functions of a, of a solar coronal mass ejection, like affecting us.
And that's not to get digressed too much, but that's what, um, Vita culture and other ancient cultures expect.
Right.
There's an alternating between floods and, and periods of like universal fire.
So, um, the last, uh, cataclysm was, uh, was a flood.
So the next one would be, um, being burnt by the sun.
Uh, like we're, however long in the future that is, like we're in the, in the, in the period of time where we,
we are struggling to awaken.
Um, to our reality in ourselves and technology gives us a mirror that we're able to use to, to me, this is like second nature.
Cause that's what astrology does.
Astrology gives us a, a mirror.
It gives us a analog simulation model that lets us see aspects of human nature that we're not capable of directly perceiving.
Cycles and patterns in human behavior that we just, we, we don't recognize them unless we have this mirror to look in that shows us.
Right.
And so technology is doing the same thing.
And, um, AI, that's, I think the purpose of AI, like, right at this time, we're going to continue to generate technologies that show us an external version of things about our own nature that we're not capable of directly perceiving so that we can see it in the AI and say, wait, that's weird.
Right.
Like it's weird that you, AI has a context window.
And once you fill it up, you got to quote, kill the AI and generate another one.
And human beings have like a certain context window.
And beyond that, they get exhausted and you have to sleep and you reboot your consciousness.
Right.
Like it's, it's, it's, it's metaphorical, but it's a metaphor to help us understand our, our nature.
And that is, I think why we, why we generate this simulation, why we're generating this simulation for building these, these pods.
And it's probably why they've done it on other levels, right.
Um, between us and base reality.
Like if it's possible that there are levels where this continues to happen, like layers of simulation.
Um, and each one is when people struggle, I think to awaken.
And so they recreate the situation to, to show them an external, I can't, I know I keep repeating myself.
It's a disturbing topic.
It's like, it's, I'm sure it's easy to understand what I'm saying, but it seems like it shouldn't be easy to understand what I'm saying.
Um, but it's real now.
We have the final feedback.
You can't argue against it.
I mean, you can argue, well, it's real, but not, we're not going through it.
Okay, that's fine.
But you can't argue that, that, that biological simulations aren't real.
You can't argue that there aren't brain cells and pods running a simulation of a first person shooter in hell.
Doom.
Right.
It's real.
Uh, it's not, like I said, it's not absolute feedback, but it's for their specific information, but it's feedback that their specific information is, is in the realm of plausible.
And once you get beyond that, like, you know, I went, as soon as my brother explained AI to me, I was a hundred percent convinced.
Um, but now that I, now that I saw this news today about them building these server farms.
Hey Morgan, do you have any desire to come up here and say anything?
You don't have to.
I mean, I imagine you would have asked, but if you do, you can, and if you don't want to, you don't have to.
Everyone loves you.
That's the thing.
Um, they love hearing for you, but, uh, you can just hang out down there if you want.
Uh, I'm just sort of wrapping it up now.
Cause I've been on my long rant.
So this is one of the point where I ask anyone if they want to, um, if they want to say anything.
Right.
We've, we've been through like 14 points of feedback.
We've been through like the final feedback and I think we've, we've established that, uh, feedback for the intuitive underground cannon, um, material is, um, more specific and, uh, more convincing than the feedback that other groups use for their material.
Um, and there's 16 people here and I'm, I'm lucky to have 16 people.
Like I, I really appreciate it.
Um, the people who are here, like, we're not gonna, uh, you know, we're not going to shift, um, the remote viewing community.
Right.
Hold on.
I'm not going to shift like the community, but at least those of us who are here will know, uh, you're up and now you're down.
You can probably talk.
Yeah.
It's my screen.
Oh yeah.
I don't know if you can hear me.
Okay.
Yeah.
My screen does all kinds of crazy things.
Who's not.
Um, okay.
Well, if you can hear me, I assume everyone can hear me well.
Uh, okay.
Well, I guess, Hey, uh, I don't have a whole lot to say.
Just think, you know, thanks for the kind words.
Very kind.
I appreciate.
Um, yeah.
The first, at least half hour, uh, of the space.
So I'll have to listen to replay later.
Josh Maitland has a streaming service.
They're charging 25 bucks a month.
Second house astrology.
Uh, I keep saying astrology because of Dan second house remote viewing.
And I was just telling the first half an hour is me telling everyone how I encouraged you
and Dan to do something similar for like 10 bucks or put out newsletters, whatever,
and how you guys were too modest and didn't like, don't want to take advantage of people
and don't want to be called like, and so you didn't want to do it at that time.
And, um, and how other groups of people don't have those compunctions and we have people
who aren't fully trained as remote viewers and definitely don't have a great record as
remote viewers become the, the face of remote viewing that has a, I mean, that's bound to
have a negative impact on the public's perception of remote viewing.
So that's, you can listen to it if you want, but that's basically what I said the first half
an hour and I also went on a rant about science blob for about 15 minutes and how people like
him are trying to intimidate people.
And that is turning us into a nation of cowards.
I don't know if you necessarily have to hear that, but if you want to hear me crash out about
science, Bob, you can listen to that as well.
So that that's the first half an hour.
Hey, I have my guilty pleasures.
Uh, do we all right?
I started with that because it's been bugging me.
Like it's bugging me.
Like just keeps coming up with this people making like intimidation and threats and people
like telling people they're going to get killed and stuff.
And it's like, if you condition, like in order to control the public through fear, you have
to condition them to respond to fear.
And if you create a public that's conditioned to respond to fear, you're creating cowards.
And so then when it's time to assert yourself in the world, when you've got a war, uh, you
know, an invasion, a pandemic, or, you know, some kind of threat, what you're left with is
a group of people that you've trained to behave cowardly.
I know no one here would ever do that, but if someone represents themselves as like a public
servant and like, Oh, you know, my service, I served, I served the government and I, you
know, I built the Aurora and you know, all that shit.
Right.
Like I, you know, I was trained by the CI, FBI, you know, DIA, whatever it is like that's
that's, that is shameful that they would, that that individual, if it's true, would then
let them go and gaslight and intimidate people in the UFO experience or community not to talk
about what they want to talk about because they could be hurt.
Right.
It's just shameful to me.
Like I, that's so yeah.
So I guess that's my guilty pleasure is being a judgmental is being judgmental of the public
personalities and the UFO X community.
I guess that is something I should feel guilty about.
Yeah.
So everyone should be paying attention to Morgan and Dan technical remote viewing intuitive
underground.com.
Uh, Morgan, what's your website?
Is it learn remote viewing?
Learn RV.
Oh no, that one.
It's the same one, right?
Like I always get it wrong.
It's all right.
It's a, I still, you know what?
It's just a placeholder website right now.
I still haven't, I haven't got the full site back up, uh, which I will eventually.
But yeah, no, the one you mean is this remote viewing training.com and there you go.
You can, you know, I'm not that hard to track down.
Anyways.
Um, you're not that hard to track down right now.
We're difficult to track down at one point in time.
You, you, you've been working on it and that's good.
It's, that's some growth.
Yeah.
Well, it's a springtime.
So I'm thawing out from my, uh, winter hibernation.
Well, there you go.
Yeah.
There you go.
No, I mean, it's like anyone who gets involved in like the community, right?
Like it's, it's this whole thing.
Like, we're not going to judge people.
We're not going to hold people to standards, or we are going to judge people and hold them
to standards that we, that we write that we come up with.
Right.
But we don't, people don't want to be, and this is the same with astrology.
Believe me, people don't want to be judged and held to other people's standards.
Right.
And so it's this whole thing of like, you know, I can go off and do whatever I want, but don't,
don't tell people that what you do, you know, might be more accurate than what I do.
It's like this code, right?
Like don't affect my business.
I won't affect your business.
I won't undermine you.
It's terrible.
It's terrible because like what you guys have done, right?
10 years of research using remote, using remote viewing into the nature of reality.
Who else has done it?
There's only one person I can think of who's done something close.
That's Edward Reardon, but his focus is on like the nature of remote viewing mostly.
He's not like five years of session data, exploring the specific nature of remote viewing.
It's not the same.
It's not, it's not, no one else has done something like this.
And the fact that you guys are modest and unassuming and, you know, relatively anonymous is what made doing it possible.
Right.
But that doesn't mean people shouldn't pay attention because they should, because we have these answers now.
Um, we have this, uh, we have the structure.
What I've talked about with Morgan is at some point, right?
Right.
Because everyone hoards.
And this is no, this isn't, this isn't necessarily criticism.
Everything I say comes across as a somatic criticism.
It's just my, you know, it's a flaw.
The remote viewers all seem to hoard RV data.
And I, I, there are a number of good reasons for that.
One being the fact they want to get paid.
The fact they want to get paid.
Right.
So some of them feel like they don't want to just disseminate data that they're not being directly compensated for.
Others might be like people who just have trouble writing reports.
Right.
There's, there are a whole bunch of reasons why it happens.
But at some point in time, we're all getting older.
And at some point in time.
Okay.
I'm just in or out cap.
There is going to be more, far more hoarded remote viewing data than remote viewers, more than likely.
And something will have to be done with it.
And other people have remote viewing data into the nature of reality, into the simulation, into related subjects.
But it's not, it's not systematic.
So in order to really organize that material, you need a structure to correlate it all around.
So it's an hour.
It's an hour before it's time for the cats to eat their final meal of the day.
They wake me up in the middle of the night.
They wake me up in the middle of the night, all the time, trying to get me to give them extra meals.
It's this one cat just keeps howling at my door to let him in.
I let him out.
That's what's going on if you can hear it.
That's what's happening.
Because he wants me to feed him an hour early.
So, yeah, back to, back to stuff.
Like there has to be a systemized set of data to, to correlate everything with.
So like if we have 100 sessions on pods, right?
We need to be able to place that relative to sessions on the light, et cetera.
And that's something that, you know, I, I strongly look at the intuitive underground material.
Like if having that sort of systematic investigation gives you the structure to organize all that other data.
Um, I think that's really how we have to look at it.
Um, so I just, I think it's, it's, it's, it's, it's irreplaceable.
That's why I, like, I keep repeating myself and saying Rosetta Stone, Rosetta Stone.
Like, I assume everyone here knows, but I don't want to be, I don't make, I don't want to be that person who, who makes assumptions.
So, you know, at one point in time, they, they couldn't read Egyptian hieroglyphics for hundreds of years.
Um, because there had been such a, a period of time between when hieroglyphics were being used and, and the modern age.
And I think it was in the 1800s, they found a stone in Rosetta, over in the Middle East.
And that stone had, um, it had writing, um, a Greek was the top level.
Don't quote me on this, but like the top level was something like Greek.
And the next level down was like Hittite.
And the level down from that was like Aramaic and the level down.
And at the very bottom, there were Egyptian hieroglyphs.
And so they were able to look at, um, they had three or four levels of languages they couldn't read.
And they used the top level, the Greek of the inscription, to decipher the next level.
Uh, we'll say Aramaic.
And then they used the Aramaic and the Greek to decipher the Hittite.
And they went all the way down.
And that is why we now can read hieroglyphics.
Because that stone was discovered.
Without that stone, we still would not be able to read hieroglyphics to this day.
That's what the intuitive underground canon material does.
That's what it gives us.
It gives us the master key to esoteric knowledge.
Another thing I've mentioned in other spaces, so I'm repeating myself again.
But recently, um, I had a question about the Kabbalah.
And, uh, when I was younger and I bought a couple of books on the Kabbalah, it just wasn't my thing.
The, the code language is not my thing.
I don't want to have to talk to someone.
I don't want to have to become a student of anyone in order to learn.
I don't want to have to wait years in order to prove myself to be able to learn the meanings of things encoded in regular language.
The very idea drives me batshit crazy.
I was bored to tears.
I put the Kabbalah away.
I learned, um, some years after that, that Kabbalah goes back to Gnosticism.
So it's a, it's a Gnostic tradition.
It goes back to Simonian Gnosticism.
And you can see the evolution of the tree of life in the Kabbalah.
You can see it from the Simonian tree of life forward until you get to the, what's the modern Kabbalah tree of life in the middle ages.
Anyhow, there's a lot of, um, dense material that usually requires a lot of study to understand.
But once you understand the intuitive underground canon material, and you have the conversations that we've had based on that, right?
We've had our own exegesis, both in, in conversations we've had between each, with each other, but mostly in these spaces.
So we've had, you know, a few hundred hours of exegesis where we've worked out the details.
We've, we've looked at the permutations.
We've come up with ideas about how things might work.
So I can go back now and look into the Kabbalah and it makes perfect sense, right?
I didn't just go into the regular Kabbalah too.
I went into the clip off the, the inverse of the tree of life left over from the, you know, the, the essences left over from the previous, uh, simulation or, um, previous universe, they would say.
Right.
So in something that takes magicians years to learn and understand, I was able to look at it in like 20 minutes and, and, and grasp it pretty well.
Now I'm not a magician.
I don't want to be a magician.
Um, it's not my thing, but it's very easy to understand once you have the Rosetta Stone of the intuitive underground material and our exegesis on it.
So that's about all I have on this final feedback.
If anyone out there wants to shoot us some emojis to let us know if you, if you agree that this feedback is pretty impressive.
Um, I know it's, um, I know it's, I know it's not pleasant to think about, but you know, to reiterate, cause I, I don't know who's here.
Who's not.
Um, cause my phone freezes up.
Uh, we do now have a feedback on, uh, biological simulations and pods and all that stuff, matrix stuff.
You can now have the feedback on.
Thank you, Shane.
Um, and we now have that, that feedback that we need to ascertain whether the IU material is possible.
Prior to this, it was in question, not to us, but to other people, you could say like, it's possible that this might not be possible in reality, but now it is.
Now we know, now we know for certain.
So, and, uh, as much as I piss people off and argue with them and, and, um, stand up for what I think is, is correct.
Uh, people get randomly pissed off at me, right?
So this happens in RV community as well, right?
People come in and tell me, um, I don't understand the universe.
I don't know anything about the simulation, et cetera.
Like I've been lied to by everybody and implying that it's, um, we have someone who was like a former associate that we were in.
Um, we're in, uh, back channels with who blasted me a few times and the, her concept, her, her, her basic argument was that I, I, there was no way that anything I knew was correct.
And, um, I'd been lied to, and I'd sort of gullibly bought into things other people said, but, you know, um, it was, it was all in my mind, basically.
Uh, I don't, I don't want to talk to that person.
Um, cause they, you know, they, they severed any communication with us, but like, that was a couple months ago.
Right.
So even a couple months ago when people come out and say like, basically I didn't know shit.
And since I get a lot of my information from Morgan's data, right?
Like they might not say he doesn't know shit.
Um, but you know, they're, they're, they're calling the IU data into question when they say that, but I'm repeating something.
Um, we also have people that I consider to be adversaries in the RV community who, like I said, they hide the data or they feed false data.
Right.
Like they have active imaginations.
And so when they do come out with stuff, they, um, they create stories that aren't in the data.
Um, and they make videos, videos that people talk about years later.
Right.
That, that taint this conversation.
Um, and because of their individual status in the community, uh, like people take that, what they say very seriously.
Right.
And like that, that's out the window now.
Like we, we've got feedback.
They don't have any feedback.
So these questions should all be, should all be fairly settled now, at least what avenue to go down.
Right.
And who to take seriously, that should be settled.
Maybe not all the details.
No.
Okay.
If anyone would like to say anything, talk, have any updates?
Um, Morgan, you got any, um, forecasts or reports in the works?
You don't have to say anything about them, but I'm just, you haven't mentioned anything in a while.
Oh, well, um, no, nothing specific, but, um, yeah, we've always, we're always working on things and working towards streamlining, um, actually putting material out there.
Uh, for me, that's one of my, one of my bigger focuses for the immediate and midterm future.
So, um, you know, I wouldn't put a timeline on it because I know better than that.
But, uh, you know, yeah, we're around, we're working and you're, you did mention earlier that we have a huge back catalog to, to get to as well.
So yes, this is, this is very true.
Um, so yeah, for me, that's kind of one of my top priorities and yeah, we are chipping away at new stuff.
Uh, I'm in the middle of a project right now.
Um, but I'm a viewer and as such I'm blind, so I don't know what it is yet.
Um, so yeah, that's, that's where we're at.
All right.
So, uh, coming up this week on, I don't know if I'm going to do a UFO X space on Friday.
Um, I don't know if my necessarily matters.
Um, so I can't say for certain, it depends on how indignant I get.
Each week I say, I'm going to do it.
And then, uh, I just get too tired.
I'm not indignant enough by the time it rolls around and then something happens and I get indignant again.
Um, uh, Thursday is our against the archons, uh, space.
The topic this Thursday is going to be, uh, 200 griefers.
Um, basically the, uh, there's a guy on, um, Instagram, um, who has developed a theory that,
uh, famous politicians and personalities and celebrities are the, um, the watchers, the Nephilim, the fallen angels.
That they were imprisoned in the earth.
We all, if you're familiar with the Bible, you know, they were imprisoned in the earth, but at some point they're released.
Um, and this theory is that the release happened a couple of hundred years ago and they've been around now out, um, running countries and serving as presidents and, and, and movie stars.
It's kind of a, it's a funny topic, but the reason that it fits with, with the, against the archons theme, both because it's interesting.
Right.
Um, in a, in a novel way, but also because when we talk about like a simulation, um, a reality overlay, we have to leave open the potential that some people from outside could access it as a form of virtual reality.
So, um, whereas the server farm, like, like doing in, in what a quarter quarter quarter call, whatever, whatever that company is, what they're doing with their Sydney server farm.
Like imagine if they started running a, like, um, I'll show you my age, like Skyrim that's, or Fortnite, right?
Imagine if they developed a Skyrim or Fortnite or world of Warcraft simulation running in these server farms with the, with the brain computers.
Uh, and then they were able to use that as the basis of a more realistic virtual reality so that when you went into the virtual reality, um, session, the NPCs you were relating to.
Right.
Weren't just programmed computer NPCs, but they were actually an NPC being run by one of those little brains.
And that's a crazy thing to say.
I get it.
But at this point in time, now this is happening.
This is actually on the table of something they could do.
Right.
So that the NPCs you'd be relating to would be sentient NPCs.
Conscious NPCs being run by those computers.
In that same way, it's possible that if we are in a reality overlay, which we believe we are, if we're in a virtual reality, which we believe we are, that some people are behaving the same way.
And so when you get into crazy stories about the elite and the things they do, it sort of makes more sense when you think of it in the terms of like briefers in a video game.
Um, Thursday, um, Saturday, uh, I want to run like a, a five things that remote viewers don't like to talk about.
I was going to say five things remote viewers are afraid to talk about.
Um, you know, but then I was, I was reassured that remote viewers aren't afraid of anything, which is admirable, which is admirable.
So we can do like five topics that remote viewers don't like to talk about aside from just the simulation.
Cause I can think of a few after a little research to come up with the full, like five or more, but like, I can think of a few right now.
I don't want to like use next week's material.
Now that people like talking to whisper when they, when they bring them up, but most remote viewers who look into it, see them, see, see, see something that they, that they then later don't want to talk about.
Uh, so that will be next Saturday and then we'll, we'll go from there.
Shane, you got anything, dude?
I know you're going to come up and talk to me earlier and I really appreciate it because I, uh, that is helpful to me.
Cause as you seen, like when I get going with a monologue, I start to get anxious sometimes and I talk faster and I don't talk as precisely.
So the reason I really rely on people is not because I'm trying to exploit people or I want people who aren't comfortable with public speaking to speak publicly, but because the, having someone to talk to slows me down.
And like makes me, you know, less anxious and helps me speak more, um, professionally.
Right.
So I, I've really, uh, my goal has been to transition to podcasting, but the problem that I've had is that I have not found anyone who wants to do a podcast with me, which is fine.
I don't mean to sound like nobody wants to podcast with me and it is, it is sad.
Um, and it does speak to my, my status.
Like I don't know.
That's just honest.
Um, and so I can understand people like, you know, uh, not taking someone as seriously if, if they cannot find someone to run a podcast with them.
But it is true.
Um, because I don't want to end up, uh, a request.
Who's requesting?
Oh, dude.
Uh, master of now.
Come on.
Okay.
So I don't want to end up like reading as quickly as possible through 90 minutes of material for a podcast and just getting faster and faster, more anxious and more anxious, which is what will happen if I don't have anyone to run it with me.
Go ahead, Shane.
Are you on now?
Dude, you're up here.
I proved you and everything.
What happened?
Can you hear me, Morgan?
Uh, yeah.
Okay.
Yeah.
You must've chosen.
It's fine, dude.
You don't have to.
I don't know why it asked me to approve you, but you can always change your mind.
You don't have to, um, say anything.
I just, I appreciate it because it slows me down.
That's all.
And I, and that's what I need for the, uh, the podcast.
But, you know, when the, when the time is right, um, the correct person will present themselves.
Right.
Isn't that what they always tell you?
Um, well, I think they usually talking about something else, but I think it'll work this way too.
What I really want to do, I'll tell you guys before I close out, what I really want is I want to be on the radio.
The radio isn't very popular anymore.
Um, however, there is a station, um, not too far from me, like four or five hours, but still, you know, not that far.
Um, that is a shortwave radio station that broadcasts around the world.
Very powerful, very famous shortwave radio station.
Now, how many people listen to shortwave?
I don't know, but you can record a podcast.
You can put the podcast online and you can also, um, rent time for very small money from a station like this and have it, uh, beamed in the shortwave around the world.
One of the things that we often talk about, and I don't have any, I've never had this conversation with Morgan where he's, he said information about this aside from the, the kill shot, which is something that comes up with all technical remote viewers.
So you could assume this might be the same thing, but it might not be right.
Right.
So it's either like the kill shot is a major coronal mass ejection and there'll be some blackouts related to solar flares on the way up there as the, we get coronal mass ejection slash magnetic bolt shift.
Um, but there could be some blackouts.
Uh, that's all right, dude.
Um, there could be some blackouts on the way to, um, not that's met.
It's a metaphor.
Like as time goes on, there could be these blackouts prior to getting to the kill, quote, kill shot.
I don't even like to use that term because people can write spice what you say and then take it out of context.
And that got me repeating like the term kill shot.
So in the row viewing the coronal mass ejection, let's say that the coronal mass ejection.
Um, one of the things that deeply concerns me that comes up in a lot of psychic data.
And with a number of remote viewers is the possibility of a, of a, of a, of solar flare induced long-term blackout that may not be a full kill shot.
Ah, fuck.
I did it again.
May not be a full coronal mass ejection.
Right.
Um, but could happen over the next few years.
And I've been concerned about it since like 2023 when it started coming up in people's data.
So every year, particularly around April, I get very nervous about it.
And I tell people to prepare that we get through April and I take a sigh of relief.
It doesn't have to be April, but that one viewer mentioned April associated with it one time.
And so I, I get extra nervous in April, but it could be August.
It could be October.
It could be a number of different times periods.
A lot of people say in the fall who see it because they see leaves on the ground, but I don't know how real that is.
Okay.
Um, like a one to three month, uh, so, uh, power outage would be a, a major catastrophe.
Um, major, especially three months, right?
That's, that's just like the EMP attack.
And you're talking about a lot of people, um, might not make it through something like that.
So I worry about it a lot.
And I spend a lot of time telling people to get ready for it, even if it's not this year.
And even if I look stupid because I don't know which year it will be, but so many people see it.
Um, and it does align with the, the idea of the coronal mass ejection as well.
The magnetic pole shift, like people see that they do.
Maybe that'll be one topic for next week.
Um, where was I going with this?
Oh shit.
I don't know.
I'm getting tired.
So we got through, uh, oh yeah.
Okay.
I'm going to end it.
I know I'm rambling.
Cause you can tell how tired I am.
Right.
Um, that's from talking without having someone to, I mean, Morgan's talking to me, but you
don't know about having a cohost.
I get very drained.
Um, if something like that happens, shortwave radio will be how people receive, um, get their
information.
Like right now technology is like another matrix.
Right.
And something like social media, it allows us all to get together and talk, but it serves
as like, um, a behavioral immune system.
It serves as an electronic immune system to ideas.
So everyone here will not everyone here, but like people out in social media will think,
well, it's a equalizer.
It allows everyone to be heard, but that's not what really happens.
It allows everyone to keep each other down.
And by making everyone equal, but limiting everyone's reach, you create these localized
bubbles where people are competing to talk over each other.
And a lot of people where everyone here might be brilliant.
A lot of people are not very brilliant, but they are very confident in what they have
to say.
And so you wind up with like something like an X where you have a good 50% of the people
who post are constantly posting things that are just aren't, aren't true.
Right.
Um, and it's, it's, it's a virtue signal.
It's not, um, it's not because they know what they're talking about.
Oh, we got a request.
T bird, T money.
I don't think we've ever talked.
Hi T bird.
Okay.
Well, until T bird talks, uh, yeah.
So that will allow us, right.
Or me or whoever I'm podcasting with to, to be prepared position.
So that when, and if there's a breakthrough or breakdown in this electronic immune system,
that's suppressing our ability to magnify this message that allow us to be ready for a time
when people will be more receptive.
And I think that this information, this new knowledge isn't going to spread until there's
a period where like all the other noise quiets for a little while and people can think about
it.
So that's what I want to do.
But of course I got to find a cohost.
Go ahead.
T bird.
I just wanted to, I listened to you all the time in your group, but, um, I think your
idea is phenomenal.
And I had one question and one comment is, um, cause I, I agree with you.
I've been trying to warn people and everyone, uh, obviously just thinks I'm absolutely nuts,
which I can be.
Right.
But it's like, right.
And you do, you start to get more crazy as you get more insulted by not no one listening,
but you're trying to warn people and you're like banging your head against a wall.
But I have, I bought a crank radio.
Now is the crank radio the same as the short wave radio?
And will that be a way to get in touch with each other?
Do you know the difference?
Cause I practiced with it.
I bought it a long time ago already, but what are your thoughts on that?
And I think it's a great idea because yeah, no one's going to have any communication
soon.
That's for, we know that we, we know that the crank radios are able to receive short
wave.
So short wave is a, is a band frequency.
So like there's FM frequencies, there's AM frequencies and short wave frequencies are
like longer, thicker frequencies.
Um, the, the, the reason that you do the bounces off the clouds and you can hear them far away.
So like FM and AM radio, you can't hear it in another country usually, but you can broadcast
from say Massachusetts and you could broadcast to Iran or Australia using shortwave radio because
the, the waves are so, uh, long and, and thick metaphorically.
Um, most radios are not able to pick up shortwave.
You have to buy one that specifically is able to, but the crank radios are designed for emergencies.
So they all incorporate basic shortwave radio in them.
There are also while we're talking about, cause that's a great idea.
There are crank generators.
They don't generate a tremendous amount of, of power.
Now, some people have like little emergency solar generators, but for it's not, look, everyone
needs all the money we can get right now.
Right.
Um, so I'm not telling people how to spend their money, but for like a hundred dollars, you
can get a crank generator that you can use to recharge a cell phone.
If you used to recharge a laptop, um, a radio or any type of emergency, it wouldn't be enough
to like power house or something like that.
It's like a hundred Watts, but it's, it's enough to like keep maybe a light on at night or something.
Um, recharge batteries for your flashlights, et cetera.
So like the crank, I'm, I'm very, um, I'm strongly in favor of crank radios and, and crank generators, um, as a emergency
solution to have like for something like during a period of blackout.
Absolutely.
Um, and like I said, if you want a shortwave radio that runs on batteries, it doesn't run
on the crank.
You have to just look for shortwave radios.
Um, shortwave receivers.
Uh, you don't want to get something that, or you could get something that you can transmit
and receive, but it's against the law to transmit on a shortwave radio without a license.
So some people sometimes buy one and they haven't broken the law until they talk on it.
And then they get in trouble with the, um, the FCC or the F, uh, whatever the radio people
are.
Right.
Uh, but if you look for something like a shortwave receiver, you can go for 20 bucks, 30 bucks.
They're not great.
Um, you could certainly pay more for them though, that they're better.
The reason that shortwave wasn't popular during the rate, the, um, the radio period is that
it's most of the frequencies you are only good for a certain time of day, like after sunset
for some of them, depending on which frequency it is.
So like AM, you could, would be reliable the whole night.
Most of the day FM would always be reliable, but a shortwave radio station, sometimes it just
doesn't, it's not able to transmit, um, at all.
So that's why there weren't any like really big shortwave radio stations.
And the radios ended up eliminating shortwave for most radios, but not from your crank radio.
You'll definitely get it.
That's amazing information.
I'm so glad I was listening and thank you for answering those questions.
I'm sorry.
I didn't recognize you.
Like I, I honestly don't, but that that's probably my, it could be two things.
Like one, it could just be me, like not having a great memory anymore, but it could also be
like, I have, I use my phone for the X spaces as opposed to a computer.
And I guess it overtaxes the phone.
So the screen freezes up all the time.
And I won't know that people come and go.
Um, and there are people that I don't see.
So I think that I would, because I generally remember like everyone here.
So I, I should remember you.
And I, I really apologize that I, that I didn't recognize you.
I don't know if we've talked before, but, but thank you for listening to all the spaces.
I really, or, or some spaces.
I really appreciate that.
Yeah.
And I've never spoken in your spaces.
I just like to listen.
Cause I'm kind of terrified of the things that have happened to me after being MRNA.
These things happen to me after, which I think is interesting too.
And I just don't talk about it in these spaces.
Cause I'm still learning from you guys, but the, the time travel and that remote viewing,
the things I see, it's never good.
It's always bad.
It's really like negative.
It's not a fun experience for me.
So I just feel like maybe there's a connection.
Cause I was so affected by the shots that did they do something to me that cause I don't
sleep ever, but when I sort of do, I guess I don't really feel like I'm here.
It's like, I feel like, I feel like I'm living a different life all the time in different
eras.
And it's not like when you had a nightmare or a dream.
I know, I know you're tired.
I'm sorry, but it's just, it's just, it's really, I try to explain this to my best friend.
Cause I obviously I don't share this with anyone.
Cause it's, it's, it's not scary when, when you time travel or remote view, you're there,
like you're living it.
Just like I'm living on earth right now.
And I don't, there's no portal.
There's no, like, I'm not, you know, when you have a nightmare and you drop through the,
this is my experience anyway.
But I see things and they give me codes.
And then I obviously then I go nuts.
I'm like, I get codes like eight, eight, eight, eight from the future.
I don't even know what year I'm in.
And, but it's so real and it's chronological for me.
Like there's no, when you dream or have a nightmare, it's all over the place.
You're like, you're here, there, nothing makes sense.
This is like a whole other life that you go into, but you don't ever feel rested.
Does that, does that, does that resonate with anyone in here?
It's like the weirdest thing.
Yeah.
Um, you know, this is something like even right now, I'm not saying you shouldn't talk about
it cause you should.
There's, um, there's a significant enough taboo around the subject that whenever it comes
up, people usually don't have much to say.
Um, the events and reaction, regardless of what a person's feelings were about the policies,
the policies were so draconian in our frame of reference that everyone is, is nervous.
They're going to lose their accounts, their financial accounts.
They're going to lose their, um, social media accounts, et cetera.
So it's hard to have that conversation unless you're talking to people who like specifically
are like, um, backs or COVID activists, depending on which you're referring to.
Um, because of that, I don't know if there's been any collection of data related to paranormal
perceptions and COVID and or the COVID vaccine.
Um, that having been said, I do know somebody when I asked them, like if they had experienced
anything different, uh, because I have not, um, received any MRA, not, not willingly.
Let's just say that who knows, but, um, it just wasn't something that I was interested in
doing.
Um, so I, I don't have the, the experience personally, although I do have, I have had paranormal experiences
in my life.
I can't ascribe them to any, um, any vaccination that I'm aware of.
Who knows?
Um, there is actually, you can make a connection with, um, fevers.
Uh, some people I know who've had a lot of paranormal experiences had strong fevers when
they were young.
So, um, I had ear infections and I had really super high, I had like 108 fever when I was
young and people I've met who've had that same experience, um, do have a lot of paranormal
experiences.
That seems to be the main thing that, that, that brought a lot of us together.
However, I don't think because of the, I don't think there's been any research done about the
vaccine and paranormal, but it wouldn't surprise me.
I do know somebody who had, um, who has seen someone out of the corner of his eye since receiving
the shots.
So the thing with that is people have a strong like emotional reaction.
And so what's hard, like what you're talking about is clearly not emotional reaction.
Like it's clearly not something that's in your head, but with a lot of people, if you ask
them like, okay, you had this thing happen, it was kind of traumatic.
You felt kind of, you have some cognitive dissonance about it because you, you, you felt like you
were doing something you didn't want to do.
Um, have you had strange experiences since you're going to get a loaded data set, right?
You're going to get people sort of maybe saying things that, that, that they wouldn't have
said before, maybe giving them an initiative, uh, not initiative, um, uh, incentivizing them
to report things that they might not have reported otherwise.
Whereas you yourself, that's not the case.
Right?
So it would be definitely, it would be very hard to do outside of some sort of like university
like it would be hard to do anecdotally here on spaces, but I have heard at least one person
make a connection between the two.
I don't know if there's any session data.
I don't remember any session data in the intuitive underground reports, um, on COVID
or on the vaccine fallout.
Morgan, do you remember anything about paranormal experiences?
I know you don't have the data in front of you.
Uh, no.
Okay.
Yeah.
So we don't have that information for you, but I wouldn't rule it out.
The, um, there is a lot of, um, conjecture, right?
Like there are things that we just don't know.
And if there's like one, if there's one thing that, that is becoming more clear, not less clear,
it's that there's a significant amount we don't know.
So at the time, a majority of people were certain that there wasn't anything we didn't know.
They were confident in the, um, in receiving the, that, the medical treatment.
Uh, but there were some people who said, look, like there's a lot, we don't know about this, or they would conjecture it.
There's like, there's like, they would have specific theories about what might be involved, right?
Technology that might be involved, et cetera.
I don't think that we've, as far as I've seen, there hasn't been much headway made in establishing.
Like what the truth is about what we don't know, right?
Like there's still known unknowns involved, but the consensus is now moving towards the fact that there are known unknowns.
And so people before who were very certain that there was nothing weird going on.
You now see them shifting to say like, there was something weird going on.
Right.
And particularly in the last couple of weeks, um, information has been coming out of the government and it's been coming out of people working in the public health sector who had a role in there, like talking about the, the number of people who, you know, you can reasonably infer died from the treatment.
So that before was completely taboo.
Like you weren't supposed to say anyone died from the treatment.
And now there are some people who are talking about in like the thousands.
And you have some people talking like in the hundreds of thousands in this country alone.
Right.
So who knows at this point, which is going to be proven to be correct.
I would suspect it's going to be in the hundreds of thousands.
I'm going to be honest.
But again, I think the main pathogen is the spike protein.
So I think it's difficult to determine which people succumb to the virus itself and which people succumb to the vaccine.
But I think a lot of us go ahead.
I completely agree.
I was an RN.
I didn't.
Okay.
Yeah.
So I didn't want it.
I was forced.
I was forced to go ahead of the virus.
I didn't want it as long as I could until they were going to fire me.
But I'm a single mom.
And then I could close down all the businesses.
I had no option even to work at McDonald's to pay for my bills or my kids.
So I had to take it.
The government sent me a letter.
I'm in Canada, by the way.
And the government sent me a letter and said, you will be at this hospital on May 4th at 8:10 PM exactly.
Like that's how, how serious this went here for me.
I did not want it.
I did all my research.
I wasn't on social media at the time either.
So I had, you know, people make fun of me and they're like, well, you deserve to be, you know, paralyzed and had two heart attacks and blah, blah, blah.
I didn't want it.
I literally was probably the last nurse in Canada to get it like that late because everyone was getting in December of 2020.
And I didn't want it.
And I took every other vaccine my whole life.
Right.
Cause we're that's mandated, but that's the difference.
This was different this time.
And I, I did do my research.
My ex-husband's identical twin brother is a scientist and he created the vaccine here in Toronto, Canada in his lab.
And, uh, I called him specifically and asked him, I don't feel like I just had, my instinct was like, this is not right.
I don't feel good about it.
I don't want it.
I don't, you know, whereas Canadians were just rushing to it cause we were terrified.
Right.
We're censored up here.
Now we're even worse.
And you're right.
Talking about it.
Probably.
I've already had the police here four times to just being honest on, on, on spaces, but I like what can I'm just telling the truth.
So, but at the end of the day, my ex brother-in-law, he said, no, it's RNA Tanya.
This is how we made it.
He went through the whole manufacturing, how they did it.
But he said, Trudeau already signed the contract with Pfizer.
So he won't take our product.
But he said, but I'm sure it's safe.
That's what he said to me.
But I still didn't feel good about it.
But then when I was forced, not that it's about my story right now, but that, and I was very, I was paralyzed for two and a half years, bedridden, dah, dah, dah.
I didn't have any remote viewing then either.
Cause I was completely like basically in a coma drooling.
But once I came out of it, you're talking about fevers, which is really awesome.
That's triggering me like high, high, high, high fevers constantly.
Like the whole bed had to be changed every single night and like really like an intolerable burning in my blood.
Like my, like your blood is boiling.
So that's really not cool, but very fascinating that you mentioned that.
But that's when after all that finally passed, that's when I started to see things.
I could see things from friends and tell them exactly where they got their tattoo.
Like that's when I started seeing that stuff.
Then the time traveling thing started with like, like I'm with Christopher Columbus and I'm like, there's, there's messages and everything.
Right.
And I sound crazy.
I know, but, but it hasn't stopped.
It just gets, and I don't want to wake up.
I would rather be there that I want to go back.
If I have to get up to go pee, I want to go back to bed and just go back to where I was.
Cause I don't want to be here.
Is that weird?
No, as a matter of fact, I, I, I think it's very understandable.
I, I sort of feel the same way sometimes about what I have.
When I have dreams, I have dreams that I sometimes far prefer to waking life.
And, and I, I will go back to sleep just so I can go back into the dream, which is something that not everyone can do, but I can do it.
Um, so I understand, I also understand being bedridden for a long period of time because I was in an accident and I was, I was in a wheelchair for a couple of years.
Um, not that I like fully, I didn't have heart attacks.
I wasn't paralyzed.
Like, so I don't fully understand, but I do understand what it's like to be, to convalesce over a long period of time and to be close to death.
Um, during that time, uh, the high fevers, the best of my understanding, and I'm not, not an expert on this, but the best of my, to the best of my understanding, fever dreams are caused by, um, the production of DMT.
So if you've ever had like a really high fever, you get the lights, the colors, whatever that's DMT in your brain.
And so if you had fevers over a long period of time that got to the point where they were producing more DMT in your brain, it would make perfect sense that you would, uh, have a greater psychic ability or have anomalous experiences at the end of that.
Um, it would be like tripping for a couple of years.
Like if you tripped on ayahuasca for a couple of years, is it possible that at the end of that, you would have like a different set of abilities or experiences?
I think so.
So it makes perfect sense to me.
Um, I'm really sorry.
I went through that.
You definitely didn't deserve that fire tax and paralyzed.
And I, I know like what they were doing in Canada was more extreme than, um, than what they were doing here, but they did try to do stuff like that here too.
It was definitely, um, the manner in which the whole thing went down is one of the reasons there were so many questions about it.
Um, because there was definitely a concerted effort to get everyone to, um, to take shots that we didn't know.
We didn't know what's in them.
We still don't.
I've, I've heard people claim to do laboratory reports and come up with anomalous material.
Uh, some of it's concerning, some of it's concerning from like an inadvertent point of view, because sometimes when you rush a vaccine to market, you get DNA in the vaccine.
And if you get DNA contamination in a vaccine, it can cause cancer.
That's something that happened with, um, with the, the, the sock polio vaccine very famously happened and is likely responsible for the uptick in, in soft tissue cancers.
Um, amongst like my parents' generation.
Um, so the, was that, is it possible that something else was included in the vaccine?
Well, I, I don't know.
Um, I think that conspiratorial people might suspect that.
I will say that not to make too much of a digression, I'll try to be succinct here.
Um, one of the spaces that I did was on, um, Dean Radden's, uh, psychic gene.
And it was actually like, it's when I almost left spaces because I only, very few people listen to the space.
And I was, I thought to this day, I think it was the most notable thought process I've, I've ever had.
Um, where Dean Radden was looking in, in the Institute for Noetic Sciences, was looking for a, um, a DNA sequence responsible for psychic ability.
And what they found was there's a DNA sequence on the seventh chromosome that's responsible for some people not having psychic ability.
Right.
So, um, about 40% of the population has no psychic ability and they have this mutation, um, mutated sequence on the seventh chromosome.
Um, the, the, the Dean Radden and who's a researcher into paranormal subjects like stuff and the Institute of Noetic Sciences, um, they, they came to some conclusions which were unwarranted by the data.
Um, but when I, when I researched that, it took me about 10 minutes, right.
Not because I'm a super genius, but because like it was clear, like the answer was clear.
And I don't know why they didn't report it.
When you look to that sequence, when you look it up online, right.
To people who aren't investigating psychic phenomenon, the purpose of that sequence, that mutation, the reason it's conserved genetically is that it, it limits the expression of endogenous retroviruses.
So what it means is that when you have that gene, it doesn't let endogenous retroviruses alter your genetic expression.
We all have these retroviruses.
Like we don't all have HIV, but people who have HIV, right.
Their body produces HIV at some point in the future, the retrovirus, um, becomes part of their DNA, right.
That's why it's called a retrovirus.
It becomes an endogenous retrovirus.
And over time it can produce, um, HIV, which is why it's almost impossible to eliminate, uh, from your body over a long period of time.
So we have endogenous retrovirus, the majority of our junk DNA, when they call it that, it's a collection of endogenous retroviruses, retroviruses that infected human beings in the past.
What we have are the like remnant sequences.
And those sequences alter the way our genes express themselves.
So if you have a gene for blonde hair, but you have an endogenous retrovirus that alters that expression, you could instead have a different color hair.
It's that type of thing.
And so what it means is, right.
A short story, extremely long and painful.
Uh, it's very likely that psychic ability, the way we experience it right now was not something people always had.
That's something people developed after they were exposed to one or more retroviruses.
The retroviruses are, are how you, um, are how you would, um, you would use retroviruses in, in genetic engineering.
Right.
So, um, not all retroviruses are genetic engineering, but that's one of the ways they do gene therapy is by engineering retroviruses.
So at some point in time, a large percentage of the population was exposed to one or more retroviruses that alter the expression of our genes in such a way that most of us are able to have some level of psychic ability.
The, um, the, the mutation stops that from happening.
And so in that people who live in those, the geographic area where that mutation is common, they have very little psychic expression.
And so that area happens to be the, the area of the Roman empire.
And the closer you get to the city of Rome itself, the higher those genes are expressed.
So that has a lot of like ramifications for the study of history and the understanding of how the world works, et cetera.
That was the purpose of that space.
It was not popular at all.
So I don't think I'm going to do another space on it, but it is very important.
Um, and I, it's like, I'm very proud of that insight.
Um, so what that means is, um, is that, you know, there could be something, um, in an MRNA cause it can transfect.
That's a fact.
They tried saying no, and I'm not, even if you were pro vaccine, I'm not making anti-vaccine argument.
What I'm saying is, is that they told people that Kim Trex could not transfect into the genes.
And it's not true.
Like they, they know it's not true.
It doesn't always transfect into the genes, but it can transfect into the genes.
It can become endogenous.
So there are some people out there whose bodies will produce spike proteins in the future.
It may always produce spike proteins their entire lives.
Right.
And if they have children, they could pass that trade on to their children.
That's not everyone.
It's not even most people, but it is.
Something that can happen if you're going to, um, conduct an experiment on a large group of people that involves some level of genetic therapy, where you have some idea that that transfection process is going to work.
And they, they had to have it because geneticists do it.
Right.
So the people who said it can't happen, they weren't being honest because it's a, it's a, it's a regular technique of genetic engineering.
So is it possible that some people, not all people, but some people got different batches?
Well, that's what they say happened.
Like they say there were different batches.
They don't acknowledge the fact that different batches may have been tailored to different parts of the experiment.
Like a lot of people don't even want to look at it as an experiment, but an emergency use authorization means an experiment.
It means you're consenting to be part of an experiment.
That's you're the final stage of research.
Right.
Um, so yeah, it's possible there was something in it.
Yeah.
I'm going to back you up a thousand percent because, because it affected me personally.
Once I finally came to and was able to think again, all I've done is research.
Right.
Cause I, I, I was a quite successful, I was a regional nursing director.
I wasn't like a staff nurse that had just started.
I've been doing this for 25 years.
Um, I wasn't an idiot.
I have a medical degree.
I was like, so I was able to, uh, get myself back to doing research at least to get to the bottom of it.
Because of course, to this day, Canadians and doctors still tell me get more shots.
Like they're safe.
Uh, you could die of COVID.
Like that's literally what our doctors still say to us today.
And I, that's why it's so horrible up here.
And I know lots of people saying you shouldn't take it.
You're a nurse.
You're an idiot.
I didn't want it, but what are you supposed to do when you're supposed to feed two kids and pay your bills?
And there's no, no businesses open, but, and that's no excuse.
It was just, I'm not against, I wasn't against vaccines.
I always got them, but this one bothered me and I did not want it.
And that's why that's what happened.
And I needed to pay the bills.
Like I don't have a husband.
I don't have anybody to pay the bills.
So back to your point in my research, you're talking about genetics.
This is crazy.
So when I heard there was DNA fragments in some of the lots, which I also did a lot of research.
I also did a lot of research on, I have an E lot and an F lot, which is, um, excess death
for E and fatal F and mine were both from Germany.
So that's actually, that is confirmed.
I have the receipts for that.
And, um, I also have met other people across Canada and North America, just in the States
here, talking to people with the same batch number that are also disabled like myself.
So we're all connecting behind the scenes.
So it's not about that.
This isn't about vaccines right now.
This is about genetics.
This is really cool.
I thought, what is the one thing that we're all, what, what is our similarity?
We tend to all be like middle-aged white women.
Most of us have good educations.
Most of us, blah, blah, blah.
Right.
So I had my DNA done in 2016 because I'm proactive and I just wanted to do it.
And I was running on a treadmill with an EKG hooked up.
I have all my medical reports saying I was perfectly, I was a super athlete, like super power.
And I just didn't like, I was totally healthy, but I just want to have a baseline.
So I have all the proof that I was perfectly healthy.
It says, right.
No cardiovascular risk at all.
Like no one in my family's ever had a heart attack, nothing.
So I get my DNA when I found Twitter, which I didn't even know existed because I was working
all the time.
So I didn't know what Facebook or Twitter or all this stuff was.
And everyone's like, you should have known.
We were screaming.
I was watching TV in 2020.
I was a nurse.
I was working 18 hour shifts because it was 2020.
So you're not busy watching TV.
You're barely seeing your own children.
You're like barely surviving, trying to like work and make sure your patients and your staff
are safe.
That's what people don't understand about a lot of nurses.
Like we, we, I didn't even know there was no toilet paper in Walmart.
Like I, cause I didn't have time to go even get Walmart toilet paper.
Like, so that, but that was my reality.
But so I, when I found Twitter in October of 2020.
In October of 2023, I heard someone saying that our DNA was changed.
And I was like, Oh my God, I wonder if I can prove it.
So I had my DNA done again.
And that's where it came back where this is a different, it was a different, um, test.
Cause I don't know.
All right.
I had my DNA done through a physician's office.
So then I did this on my own and it came back.
And the first thing that came up was I had a very high percentage of Neanderthal.
And I was like, I was laughing my butt off.
I'm like, what?
I'm like, Oh, one of my parents are going to be really pissed off.
Then I find out Neanderthal genes are only passed through the mother.
That's new.
And we were, and I'm like, well, then where did Neanderthal come?
I'm, I'm Catholic, but I'm like, but I always wonder.
Cause my ex husband's atheist and he believes in, you know, you know, anyway.
Um, so I look it up and I'm like, Neanderthals mated with modern humans.
And I'm like, well, what's that?
Where did the modern human, is that an alien?
I literally was saying this in spaces and the result came back then.
And I was asking everyone and no one was answering.
And then it gets even worse.
Wait till you hear this.
Genetics.
Way beyond, you know, Epstein files and stuff.
I don't even get into that.
I don't, I don't want to know.
I don't, I don't go.
I'm not, that's not my thing.
I feel terrible.
Anyway, someone heard me speak in spaces about this, that I believe that Neanderthals
might've been targeted in some way, for some reasons, genetically.
I was trying to figure out like, why me?
Right?
Cause when you're, when you hit, just like if you had a car accident, why you, how are
you still alive?
These are the questions you asked.
How am I still here?
Like, is it, is it, you know?
Anyway, someone sends me all these documents and they're like, they found these Epstein emails
that show George Church and, uh, was it Nakao and, uh, Epstein, the two Jeffrey Epstein saying
that they found the Neanderthal genome and that they could finally recreate, um, a superhuman.
I shit you not.
I have the email and I'm like, I don't know if it's, I mean, I don't, I'm not an IT person,
but then other people started sending me more stuff because I had been talking about this
for three years now.
Cause I, it was just in my, again, right?
It's in your instincts, right?
That's why I love the topic was intuitive.
And there was just something that it wasn't sitting right in my gut.
So back to the genes, I was like, how come everyone else is okay and I'm not and why me?
But my sister's also really sick and my mother's really sick.
And so, and she, my mother had a heart attack and my, like, it's just crazy where we are
all perfectly healthy.
And, um, so anyway, I just wanted to share that information with you.
Cause it's, it's not, not so much about this.
It's just all so intertwined, right?
Like everything is, it's so crazy when you look at the big picture and I don't think people
do that.
Thank you.
So, um, you are, that that's, that's definitely accurate about the Epstein files and Neanderthal
genes and Epstein wanted to create Neanderthal hybrids.
I know it sounds odd.
I know it sounds strange.
People listen to our spaces are using Epstein was deep and, and, um, his, his wife or his,
his, whatever his partner were very deeply enmeshed in paranormal subjects, UFOs, Atlantis,
break out, breakaway civilizations.
And they wanted to use the ranch that they had in New Mexico for doing genetic hybridization
research on human beings.
Uh, that, that much has been established from the, um, Epstein email documents.
Uh, what, what T bird, uh, is pointing out, um, and I, I, if they drop me, I'm going to use
another phone cause my battery's running low, but this is an important thing.
Um, I've never thought to do a space on this.
Uh, I'll never do a space.
And this isn't you.
Um, I did touch on Morgan's data for the vaccine earlier.
Like we do lose people.
Um, when we talk about this subject and.
Um, we might lose people like permanently if they feel very strongly, if they're very strongly,
um, against any criticism of, of the vaccine, COVID, et cetera.
And it's not a matter of, um, of wanting to be a people pleaser.
It's that our other information is so important that we prioritize that information and getting
that out to as many people as possible.
It's not that COVID isn't important.
It's just that, you know, we're talking about like the very nature of reality.
Right.
Um, so that's why I don't do spaces on the COVID vaccines.
I'm not really afraid.
Like I, you know, um, I I'm, I'm also someone who's been through like some setbacks in life.
and like right now it's a lot you can talk about these things if that changes and there's more
setbacks in my life because of it because of something i said in an x space there's nothing
i can do about that i've been so outspoken about so many things in my life that whatever there's a
list about people who talk about crazy subjects i've got to be on it already not that i'm saying
it's crazy you know what i mean um i totally i'm so sorry i i know it's okay i mean vaccine i just
i just thought it's just interesting the genetic component yeah no no i'm gonna answer that right
now it's important right so earlier in this space i basically i never finished my thought
but what i was basically telling people is that um if we're living in a simulation a lot of the people
like they were never people walking around they're like brains on a chip right so if i'm gonna run a
space where i tell people like hey we could live in a simulation and not just that but most everyone
here could be like you know not a person in a simulation but like an or a brain organoid you
know in a tub someplace like obviously i'm gonna end up on the crazy people talking list even if i
phrase it as like entertainment or as a thought exercise like i've already i've already crossed that
line right so don't apologize it's just that i'm just letting you know why that's why we won't do a
space on it like fully um neanderthals yeah so um that was in like science fiction literature
for years um but it was something that was like denied and there were some of us who knew it was
true but they only admitted in 2006 2008 to hominid intergression right so that we were hybrids
up until then it was a theory um so as you probably know like there are people who have um uh some
neanderthal genes and some more than others um people in east asia who have denisovan genes and
people in um uh the pacific islands who have uh denisovan genes we don't those of us who are
european descent don't really have um there are at least two ghost species that we don't even have a
name for them but we have been able to identify the patterns and the genetics and there are there
are people who have uh genes from what's referred to as homus erectus you know i don't want to i don't
want to set off uh uh like if duma was here who would make some sort of juvenile comment um
so that's a very real thing that's something they didn't acknowledge until very recently but the genes
that we the reason so when you everything genetically right now you know this as a nurse but like people
who listen like i'm sure most of them do but some of them might not right so like if you if you um
have a genetic trait that's really bad uh for you and for everyone else um you don't have children
or over a period of a few generations you don't have children like the traits that we have the genes
that we have are conserved for some reason some of those genes make us sick you know the reason those
genes are conserved is because when you have one copy of them you have some sort of advantage
right so if you have one copy of a sickle cell anemia gene you're resistant to malaria if you have two
copies you have a death sentence if you have one copy of a cystic fibrosis gene you have a stronger
immune system if you have two copies you have a death sentence um so like it's not good for the person who
has it when people say well like why would god let these genes be you know people get sick well it's
it's conserved because it's it adds to survival advantage of the majority of people who have those
genes and neanderthal genes are conserved most of the neanderthal genes were conserved related to the
immune system so or at least as far as as they know are related to the immune system like uh people who
have neanderthal genes tend to have stronger immune systems right um
it's also possible there's been a theory that's kicked around for some years
that and i i am not i'm there's no judgment here at all and there's no like shit talking there's no
nothing inferred or implied or whatever right but it is a valid theory that's kind of taboo
and so it hasn't been fully investigated that neurodiversity is related to hominid introgression
okay the reason that we have is we have more neurodiversity as a species than any other species
has and you just measure that through behavior so we have a diversity of behavior that related to
neurological hard wiring that you don't find in other species as a matter of fact like if if two
little birds look the same but one of them acts completely different like you usually speciate
that you say it's a different species and we don't say that with human beings
so it's quite possible that neurodiversity is the legacy of the of the hybridization
because that's what prominent integration is it's hybridization like we're hybrids
right but not necessarily hybrids of human beings and grays it's human beings and neanderthals
our cousins human beings and denisovans our cousins human beings and at least three other
early hominid species
uh there is a that is so that is such a great analogy and i've never heard it that way
and did you hear just i think it was just this week they found a new archaeological and again i'm
very open-minded i want to i don't tunnel vision i want to learn about everything i want to know why
why right so i'm not like i'm like hell-bent on one way or the other everyone i all pro-choice about
everything if you want to keep doing it do it it didn't do good for me personally it hurt me but
that's my my experience right just but but i want to make that clear like if i try to warn people what
happened to me because it's not fun but i think it was genetically it wouldn't have matter what batch
maybe i got right but i need to get the bottom of it so i love what you're telling me about but they
came up with a new uh it's different than neanderthal different than denison but this this week did you
hear they just came up with a new species they found archaeologically and i can't remember the name of it
now i don't i don't know that information but i believe you yeah yeah it just this week but i can't
remember anyway it might be this there what they originally thought were denisovans in china they're
calling like dragon man um that could be what they're referring to i'm not certain about it that
just that's been the like what exactly is going on with the the fossils they found in in china um
so yeah i don't know if when my battery runs out if i'm able to switch devices in order if we're just
going to drop the space so i'm not trying to talk over you i'm just trying to get this out um
yeah if uh if neurodivergence is a factor is related to hominid intergression to the hybridization of
human beings and it kind of makes sense because if you think about it the traits we tend to connect
with neurodivergence right in all its forms tend to be behaviors and and ways of approaching the world
that are um more introverted and uh better suited for living in small groups so of the various ancestors
we have as far as we know human beings are the only ones who lived in communities as large as we do or
even back in the day communities as large as they did right so homo sapiens lived with 150 people
and neanderthal man lived with six to 15 okay so like things like the perseverative interest where you
you learn as much as you can about a subject that makes a lot of sense if you're living in a in a
small community of like six to 15 people who have to conserve all of the information
um as opposed to um spreading that out in in a larger community
um so it's called uh the neanderthal theory of autism and i recommend it it's not offensive um it could be
offensive to someone like like just on like a principle but the theory itself and the person
made it's not offensive it's not um they have a quiz like you can take it uh you know see how many
like traits you have um that may be related to like having neanderthal genes again it's it's hypothetical
it's it's a it's a theory um but it it's interesting because yeah epstein was um was tied in with the
manufacturer of the of the mrna technology and he was very interested in hybridization um and neanderthal
genes um and if if it's true that they tie into neurodivergence then everyone is very interested
because the idea is that you could learn to tailor someone's neurodivergence for the role that they
would play in society so if you wanted computer programmers you could find people with a
neurodivergence who made them better computer programmers or pilots or sort of be controllable
um am i saying that's what happened no but it that's a very thing thing that i hadn't thought
about uh particularly when you talk about like the ties between neanderthal dna and um and the
immune system now that's an argument in favor of the neanderthal theory neanderthal theory of autism
because there's a strong autoimmune component um and because of the strong autoimmune component
in quote the autistic spectrum like in that that neurodivergence spectrum um
people often see that as evidence that it's related to some sort of toxic exposure
or you know it's something dietary or something like that it's a inflammatory reaction but in fact if
it's related to the the the dna um from these cousin um species then uh then you would see right you'd
see that autoimmune conditions from a heightened immune system are quite possible like that higher
level of inflammation um would be an explanation that would avoid like the idea that there's some
sort of toxic sickness involved uh it's a very loaded subject but you know um maybe we should do a space
on it sometime and i'll see how alienated people get and if people get really alienated with my spaces
then i'll do a i mean it's not something people should be you know it's who we are right and when
people someone says to me like all my life i was from a different world so therefore you know maybe i'm
i'm a soul from a different world i mean that's possible but it's also possible that the reason for
that is that we're not one uniform like we're not like one ancient crocodiles have been around 200 million
years human beings haven't like we were a whole bunch of different species who merged into one species
so if you have a stronger amount of those traits like you definitely would feel like you were living
in an alien planet or you were different from everyone else around you because you would be
your consciousness would be the way you would look at the world would be right neanderthals perceive the
world more visually entirely visually in fact so if you talk about someone who doesn't have an
internal monologue or like only perceives things in images that's like um that's a way of thinking that
was very common with other hominids um and when you look at the the type of intelligence involved
you're definitely not talking about um a regressive or primitive intelligence at all you're talking
about like it's but it's possible i'm not saying this is true but it's possible that human beings in
general homo sapiens are like barrier for an ancient signal right where like a lot of what we accomplish
is the result of the when you have hybridization the genes of the smaller contributor
are overly represented in their traits right so you could say that the other species that we hybridized
are the species whose genetics are responsible for a lot of what human beings have done
um and a lot of like what has changed about us um over time right like civilization and inventiveness
and technology and and things that we may not have been able to do it at one point in time before that
all began it was definitely shouldn't be like uh you know saying someone is descended from a caveman
that's not what it is at all right i mean we could substitute like gray for neanderthals it's not
accurate but we could say like what if there were a small group of aliens from a super advanced
civilization that hybridized with us in in lieu of the neanderthals these are all right that cross my
mind that's why i'm like i'm not judgment yeah i just i just wanted to share my experiencing like i've done a lot of research but
thank you for backing me up on that because i do sound like nuts absolutely for normal people that i talk to
that are just average and don't have an intuitive anything they just they're just vacant right it's
like they're whatever they're i don't even know these terms anymore but i did find the name that was found
two days ago so i put it in your purple pill it's it's the new one that i just found so i just wanted
to make sure because i can't message you and and i did want to say like you're right like i i'm not
offended i mean i laughed at first i'm like oh my god i'm a i'm a caveman or i'm like you know i don't
think i look like one and i joked about it at first but then i was like then it just hit me i'm like oh my
god this is a huge sign that was in 2023 way back and i started talking about it and everybody told me i was
crazy and i should stop talking about it and but well there are a lot of subjects that you only talk
with certain people about right because everyone else is going to and they're also you're in canada
and i don't mean that disrespectfully of canadians but what i have discovered in the limited number of
relationships i've had with canadians is that other cultures aren't as um haven't been as um
steeped in the paranormal it hasn't been normalized to the same extent so that people from say canada
not everyone right because it's morgan's from canada but like some people that i've talked to
from canada react the same way to these type of conversations that that adults did when i was a
kid but like you know regular normal modern americans that i that i run into like don't react that way
anymore right so it's it's like sort of like we're like the hub of the weird thinking and it's more
normalized here and then the further you get from here like the the stranger a person who talks about
it is i don't know that's just my experience it could be that i'm just being very um uh cultural
centric or something but i no you're right you're 100 hey i'm canadian i've been here my whole life
and i've met a lot of americans i love the americans they're the ones that taught me everything about
the vaccines i didn't i didn't know anything you guys you get like i didn't know there was a vaccine
injury compensation program in canada an american told me that that's how censored we are up here
i'm in canada and i didn't know no one's just to this day no one knows so that's i i count on you
guys i depend and if we lose connection that's why when you brought up the crank radio and the short
wave radio that was really important and you hit my soul when you said when you don't feel like you
belong i've never felt that way and not that this is my personal story but i've always said i don't
belong here i never had any friends i i couldn't fit in with people i was in those stupid gifted
programs where i was isolated and god knows i don't even remember some of the stuff i did now
but i do remember that was most of my life i was not i was not included in a lot of things i was
isolated in different little pods and i just always said and i'm literally i gotta tell you this and maybe
this is the wrong thing to say it loud but just like i'm 51 years old and only a month or two ago
i was able to ask my dad he's dying he's old he's very old he's almost 90 but i asked him i called him
in the middle of the night and i was just like really upset because i had a vision and i just
decided i was going to call him and he answered and i said i need you to be honest with me i don't think
i'm doing good and i know you're not and before you go i don't think i'm from here i don't know
where i'm from but you need to be honest with me before you go anywhere what planet am i from i
literally asked him i never asked him never brought it up once and he says oh didn't even falter
planet vestidious didn't and i said what and he said vestidious and i'm like what the heck is that
and i said can you spell that for me and i was like half asleep and i wrote it because that's what
you do in your remote view too right you always have a pad at your well i do anyway and i take
notes i draw pictures when i'm i just and then i remember the next day but yeah so that kind of
freaked me out because it was just there was no pause it was just the answer and i don't know if
you've ever heard of that but that's like that's why my mind is so open because you hit me there
it's like when you don't feel like you fit in and you don't belong here and you just never did
but you kind of make yourself fit in it's it's it's a very isolating existence and i i'm sure you
understand that if yeah if you said it yeah
uh i'm gonna assume jt's having connection issues uh which is to say he'll probably be back
momentarily
in the meantime let's see if my screen's up to date who we got
t-bird well you were just talking so hello uh alien blue bark like a duck melissa susan sadie
benjamin mary mama steve sinan was a yagmer oh look at that holy moly i thought we were done
uh yeah my phone died so i went to switch to another device and it wouldn't let me back in so i apologize
that that happened uh t-bird i i uh you were 51 or you offered when you were talking to your father
and then i didn't hear anything after that and i i um i don't mean to be dismissive i just was having
technological difficulties that's okay i just said i just asked my dad point blank i said you hit me in
my heart when you said you don't feel like you're from here and i've never felt that way and you heard
all that and i just called my dad well the night and he answered and he's like old really really old
and i just said what planet i actually point blank asked him what planet am i from and he didn't even
hesitate he said plant uh uh vestibius oh nice yeah well i don't even i don't even know right so
i was saying i always keep a pad and paper on my because when you remote view you i tend to write
things like a crazy person when i wake up in the next morning i'm like what the heck happened last night
or i do one time i was a samurai and like when i because i time travel too in my mind in my mind
just not like i don't want to freak anyone out but it's very detailed like the details that i have
are crazy and then send me down rabbit holes for hours and hours and hours and hours days and days
but yeah that was it he didn't even falter he just i said what dad i know you're dying and i'm not doing
well what planet am i from i just i need this closure and he didn't even hesitate he said vestibius
and i'm like okay that doesn't make sense to me how do i spell it and he spelt it and he said
okay you got your answer good night and he hung up i'm like i've never heard this but i then i google
it and it's like supposed to be a volcano or but it doesn't but but he said i asked him what planet
i'm from so now i'm like i don't know anything about planets or aliens or anything but anyway so
that's why everything comes together for me i'm like what when you don't fit in you didn't you just
don't fit in and it's not a it's not a fun feeling living this long not fitting in i just you hit me
there thank you yeah i mean so that's the whole thing right so there's particularly part of oh jesus
is getting into some really taboo this is worse than the vaccine um not what you said what i'm about to
say so when you get into identities right and the sense that people have um you know there's a tremendous
um argument about biology the biology of sex versus gender versus identity and uh i don't want to get
into that political argument but at the root of that like things can be true on a number of different
levels right so like i can't i'm not qualified to debate gender or the different i'm too old to be
honest with you it's like this is a generational warfare aspect of it like so i don't even get into
like people how they identify but during that process other types of identification sort of started to
emerge and they weren't taken as seriously so there's like other kin which is identifying as another
species or a hybrid like so starseed is a type of other kin now i'm not making um an argument for
against i'm not getting into like is there a biological basis any of that what i'm saying is
uh if somebody feels right as a result of neurodiversity or the sense that that that they
are different from other human beings like there is that we can say there's like a potential biological
explanation for there could be a soul explanation there could be a uh an alien explanation there could
be an other kin explanation there can be a gender there could be all kinds of neurodivergence like
all those things can be very real but at the same time you know it is quite possible that the variation
in human consciousness is the result of the fact that we are a hybrid species right and that's people
will see reports from scientists saying like because there was one recently about human beings being
hybridized and everyone was like in the in the ufo community misunderstood that and interpreted it as as um
confirmation that some scientist was saying you know confirmed there are aliens hybridizing with
human beings and there may there may well be however what that was about was that our our
historical hybridization is a fact so if you know if a person has you know just even two percent
of a of another species dna in them um because of the process of hybrid integration um that two percent
the traits related to the two percent are going to be highly um over um overrepresented that's why like
you're able to um hybridize apples or any type of hybridization you do um the the species that
contributes the lowest amount of dna the the the traits related to that are very um are overrepresented
but to an extreme um so they might even be the dominant traits of the hybrid organism so if you
have two percent or four percent of uh of the dna of another species right that that could very well like
which genes relate to consciousness we don't know is it possible that you know for instance neanderthal
adenosovan dna that some of the conserved genes relate to consciousness in some way absolutely
it's absolutely possible i don't think it's been identified but is it possible sure
so yeah i mean it could be that there's a at the root of it that you know the the sense that people
have you know regardless of how much we can prove the other aspects of it right because it could be like
okay what if the fact that we're hybridized as hominids allows some people
to be vessels for spirits or souls from other places like that's i'm not saying that's true i'm
saying that's one hypothetical situation that comes immediately to mind which would make it true on
more than one level right so that perhaps people who have a certain amount of neanderthal adenosovan
dna or certain genes or certain um endogenous retroviruses like a person who's psychic who has
an endogenous retrovirus that enables their psychic ability right some combination of those factors
enable certain people to identify with to synchronize with to commune with or even to receive
walk-in spirits or souls or identity or something like i don't even know if i have the language at
this point to fully describe it but i'm saying it could very well all be related um that's a fantastic
point and i think people are afraid but also unknowing i i i went to medical school so i worked on cadavers like
it was really creepy when you walked in there i felt differently than the other medical students i felt
like this like it i i can't even explain it and to see all these bodies on gurneys that were basically like
green in this cold huge room it's a very very good medical school and it's vintage right and it's like
it's biology it's simple biology so if we have staphylococcus aureus growing on our skin all the time
then you have mrsa methylacillin resistant well guess what our staff mutated for the host style right
it's just basic biology to me but some people don't think like that or parasites everyone has parasites
right like we but people don't want to picture parasites in your gut people don't want to picture
parasites in your brain so but that's why i'm so open i'm like did so you know the mrna there's
scientists that are proving that silkworm which is a very specific parasite was attached to this
nanoparticle and then the technology with so that's why the aliens epstein parasites biology normal
humans neanderthalic it all comes in like a full circle for me and i'm just i'm just trying to put
the pieces together to understand humanity or whatever we are transhuman whatever i am now so i love what
you're saying i i love because it's like an x files right like it's like the the whole taking the entire
10 years of x files and squishing into one um one event or you know one short period of time yeah i
i mean that's whatever the truth is we're gonna find out it's really weird i'll say like with the
genetic stuff like that that's a subject that is more was written about it significantly more was written
about in the 80s and 90s than is available online now a lot of the books and articles never transitioned
to online and it's not a popular subject um however people who are part of the ufo x community or ufo
community are probably familiar with the concept that some hypothetically some of the alien species
people encounter could be chimera they could be genetically created organisms created by human beings or by
another alien race so that if there are like fish men lion men bird men there could be species out
there of fish men lion men and bird men but it could also be that one species created chimera of
fish men lion men and bird men right genetically engineered these uh beings um another thing that
no one talks about now and i'm not saying it's true i'm not saying any of this is true i'm just
telling you what people have said and written about that i'm aware of uh there was some
speculation or um at one point time people were discussing the possibility of um genetically
hybridizing people with dolphins and the purpose of that genetic hybridization with dolphins would be
to enable a greater psychic ability now am i saying it that's what happened no um i will say that when
the indigo kids started coming around in the 90s one alternative theory for how that happened it recently
made a comeback a year or two ago but as usual the people start talking about it and then they just
i'm not saying they disappear but they disappear from like online life or you know no one follows up on
their information or they said that it's possible that some people have hibernized with dolphins as weird
as it is am i saying it's true no but it's like a persistent um legend or a persistent folk tale
that's been around for like 40 or 50 years now that that was something that someone might try to do
um going back to the early um russian psychic research that preceded the uh beginning of the um stargate
and sri remote viewing programs right because the russians were way into that with their psychic
program and exposing people to um interactions with dolphins i don't know um but that's like when indigo
kids started coming out that's one of the theories people had uh your guess is as good as mine i think
it would probably show up in the 23andme data so i think it's highly unlikely that anything like that
would happen um and that we wouldn't know about it but like is that something that someone might try at
some point yeah hell yeah right i mean that's maybe not now maybe it hasn't happened yet but like in the
future if someone's like hey just just take this this uh injection everything will be fine bob and then you
you know people develop a dolphin head um it would be freaky there's this but it wouldn't surprise me
there's this movie melissa mccarthy's in it it's supposed to be a comedy and i did i didn't want to
think about anything seriously one night and like i just want to watch something on netflix and just like
chill and just like laugh and it's uh oh gosh what's it called and it's with jason bateman and
she gets inject it's it's the exact what you just said and then jason bateman is like half crab he's
got the crab so what do i do the movie took me five hours to watch because everything i watched i took
notes and i'm like wait a minute why is he a crab why i just take notes and i'm like yeah did you know
we come from crabs yeah i did the research because i was like why are they why are they showing us this
right and also what the hell's the movie you got to watch it it's like when you watch it and she's
eating like raw poultry and she has all these superpowers suddenly after she gets all these
injections and then she falls in love with jason bateman who has the claw the the crab arms i mean
it sounds ridiculous but i took everything the same with salt i did all the decoding of salt that's where
i found out chickenunga and dengue and all the different codes for all of that if you actually
take screenshot it'll take you 10 hours to do it but but if you have nothing else to do why not
but so i gotta tell you the funniest thing that you just said my best animal um my best animal
vocal is the dolphin i've been doing it my whole life but wait wait a second i gotta do it
does that not sound good yeah that's pretty good that's pretty good i've been doing that for years
well if you go swimming with the dolphins and they they they seem to have an unusual kinship for you
then maybe there's something to the story i'm gonna say like the crab men thing like so people like
originally you know when you'd have like podcasts radio shows right coast to coast am and like the
beginning of ufox as far as i understand it from what people told me it was the people with the more
offbeat hypothetical stories that provide like the most interesting conversations it doesn't mean that
everyone takes believes everything right but like it's definitely something that people want to hear
like oh that's interesting even if they don't believe it the more far out stuff is like a is a draw to
people so i think people are happy now this crab man thing keeps coming up and i i don't know about
people being descended from crabs that one took me a little bit off guard i'm going to be honest with you
um i have difficulty uh uh believing that but i do know that like that's a that's some sort of like
meme in the ufox community that has never understood where they where they refer to crab people and
people who have had experiences with crab people it's like a story i missed um entirely and i never
understand what they mean so maybe it's a joke and a meme that i just don't get or maybe you're saying
people are descended from crabs and in which case i don't know but no i mean honestly there's something
to do with our genetics and honestly i didn't i'd never i don't i was never part of a ufo community
this is why my brain is so open i'm like what what what okay there's got to be some symbolism why would
do you have crab arms he's a totally normal human looking and then it's supposed to be a comedy and
i just take everything too seriously and i'm bored obviously but then it's like then i do i do these
deep dives on my laptop while i'm watching movies like a like an autistic person like you said earlier
and maybe i am probably but it's just like but it's fascinating because it keeps my brain going
at least because i'm not working and i'm stuck here and i am i'm 51 years old i'm not a young person
but when you live through your whole life and then you hit this point where you've been so
out of the loop you had no idea what the world was about you're just running the rat race constantly
and then suddenly this is actually exciting for me like but but that's what i actually the research
that i found was yeah there's some kind of genetics with crabs and humans i can't remember
to the details but yeah you guys have to look at that movie melissa mccarthy jason bateman
it's supposed to be a comedy and it kind of looks like a batman beginning like you know the pow pow or
whatever and so i think it's going to be funny and then it turns into a research project
well i mean look the thing is even if we are in a which we believe we're in some kind of simulation
reality overlay um things happen there are narrative storylines in the in the simulation in the reality
overlay and some of them are quite interesting and one of them seems to be human beings being
genetically modified in some way at some point if not many times i just i hope to god that no one spliced
us with a crab um but you know um like that's not even the craziest thing i've heard this week
so i don't even know what the craziest thing i heard this week is but it's probably not that
i mean i i hope it's not there's no reality to it um i mean i know what you're saying is true like
there's some sort of genetic connection i'm just what i'm saying is i'm hoping it's it's um convergent
evolution right so it is possible to have uh similar genetics even similar traits it's even possible to
have two animals or species that look identical that are actually genetically completely unrelated
to each other through the process of convergent evolution crabs are one of the um species that's
mentioned because the uh alien light i'm letting you up so crabs are one of the species that's mentioned
because crabs have evolved more than one time according to science so um it is possible that we
have genetically we're genetically similar in some way to a crab or banana um without being evolved from them
um i think it had something to do with spinal that the spinal and the and then that's all i remember
yeah well i just that's the one you know i'm gonna say like that's it's pretty far out but i really
definitely hope that there's no um that you know the anunnaki didn't inject us with crab genes
me too i like i don't believe anything i'm saying i think you know you could have a space hypothetical
scenarios maybe then it's covered yeah and so that's like that's something if you you know to
to develop they used to do this to develop people's minds they would try to teach them to entertain more
than one idea at the same time or to believe both things that are demonstrable and things that aren't
demonstrable at the same time like to stretch the mind they don't teach people to do that
anymore but it's it's very valid like you can talk about things you don't believe you can even be
excited about them you can feel passionate about things that you don't necessarily believe are true
alien light what do you got
so i let alien light up as a speaker but yeah thank you
i can hear you now thank you is it okay is it okay to speak of quantum physics in relationship
ship to what you're speaking of sure absolutely uh first let me ask because i'm looking at your picture
it doesn't look like a crab person necessarily but it doesn't not look like a crab person so
i just want to make sure am i speaking to a crab person
i'm just being facetious i know you're not a crab person go ahead
i don't understand what you mean i'm just joking around dude i'm getting tired i'm kind of punchy
and i'm just we were talking about crab people and then you said you want to talk about quantum
physics in relation to what we're talking about so i i asked if you're a crab person but i was being
facetious it's just it was just me tired trying to i got you okay right no problem thank you okay
yeah quantum quantum physics uh the electric magnetic color spectrum light yeah that exists
everywhere night and day space earth anyone familiar what quantum physics is expressing right now of that
uh i don't know i don't know if i'm familiar with what quantum physics is expressing about the light
but maybe um okay i'll i'll just be very brief right it's the living loving colors we're posting
right now it's related to the electric magnetic photos senses of the sunlight light is piercing
it is of your existing night and day you exist in this color dimension night and day without no biology
not only humans all of life exists in this photo senses illuminative light dimensions that we are
pulsing night and days it's deflected make a radiation light deflection that actually exists invisible to
all to humans but in the spectrum of this existence some of creatures on nature can see it we exist in
this dimension this dimension is very cohesive very intelligent it is of an unknown origin of life that
it sends a cohesive specific color spectrum the specific color spectrum are the potential ph
color spectrum that everyone is familiar with starting at the bottom red uh orange uh green um um i just i'm
not for i'm i'm going too fast uh white white at the top is blue orange in the in the middle at the top blue to uh pink
right these are the photosensors color spectrums they are extremely cohesive
without this cohesive wavelength of 400 to 700 no reliving biology can exist your heart is
tuned into this biology it is in the form of conscious to subconscious subconscious subconscious is
the true origin of the dimensional signaling that you are tuned into and receiving and transmitting from
but receiving on both ends of the conscious and subconscious existence of the transmission of this uh dimensional signaling
it is very real it is very cohesive extremely intelligent it is in the photo census color spectrum as i mentioned we're
showing it posting it constantly i just posted a video of it just a few minutes ago has anyone seen them
you said you'd be brief and then i got bounced from the space and then it wouldn't let me back into the space for two minutes
uh i don't think it had anything to do with what you were saying i think you're probably on the level
i'm sorry that i didn't hear it you can repeat if you want or everyone else heard it and maybe that's what's important
um i don't mean to be you know because i'm speaking of your if you if you're if you understand quantum
physics and it's speaking of you just right now and i'm trying to communicate with intelligence as i said
quantum physics people that understand the wavelength of 400 to 700 you would understand the importance of
what i'm trying to express here uh social media is not right or intelligent it's too occupied with just
stories this is not stories this is now if it didn't exist now can you exist right now let me ask you
something anybody listening right now right may i and i'll just ask one question of intelligence can i yeah go ahead
all all all telecommunication all communication cannot exist if this uh the wavelength did not
exist in the color spectrum right this way the same color spectrum life is only on earth it's not found
anywhere else it's not found on the moon it's not found on mars do you see any intelligent wavelength
of dual color spectrum that see one is a rainbow before lightning which is a dimensional very powerful
expression of the dimension of this college dimension is that is that exists anywhere else or anywhere
right so is this here on earth because it shows that it's here on earth
that's interesting to you now you need all those in the hydrogen potential compression cohesive intelligence
it is not stupid it is not random it is where you are receiving your intelligence from constantly
when you need to download where does it come from it comes from the dimensions of the color spectrum from
sunlight signaling thank you your social media is not ready for intelligence yet
you're gonna ready only for your story world have a good day yeah i mean i don't know if social media
isn't ready for intelligence perhaps i'm not ready for intelligence alien light i i don't know that i
really appreciate you coming up as a speaker and beginning by repeating over and over again that you're
only talking to intelligent people that we're not intelligent people and that social media isn't ready for
intelligence though i think he dipped entirely right after me letting him make his answer his question so
it's like if people are going to behave like terrorists and drive-by shooters metaphorically
speaking it's just counterproductive like why like yeah a lot of us are offbeat
and you know a lot of us have had difficulties in life from being a little offbeat but you know just going
around and jumping in spaces and then pissing in people's ponds and then dipping dude oh and then
being a coward about it not even staying just just just taking off right after i let you go it's just
such a scumbag thing to do everyone in this space is intelligent obviously and um i don't know he doesn't
think social media is ready for the his intelligence and the color spectrum isn't on any other planet
and that's how we know life isn't on any planet it didn't sound very intelligent to me but i'm not in
you know admittedly whatever category he's concerned with i am not in that category so um maybe i will
never be intelligent enough to understand what his point was um i i could have gone my entire life without
knowing that though uh sorry sorry morgan uh sorry t sorry everyone else um i like to give people a
chance even if what they're gonna say is um is not i don't know even if what they're gonna say is not uh
isn't with the isn't with the um the topic isn't topical um and even if they sound kind of cranky or
maybe they've been drinking a little bit or something um i do like to give people a chance to speak because
i mean this is like a forum for public speech right and it's sort of a i know no one really
thinks of it like this but me but it's sort of like athenian you know this is a very athenian
model of you know if all of us all hanging around talking asking questions transmitting knowledge to
each other that's ideally how it should be uh what's up dave um
you you know why the plato wasn't named plato plato means uh something like uh uh muscles
or bulky or something like that so i forget what plato's real name was to be honest with you but it
wasn't plato plato was what they called him because he was like um a greek version of like a weightlifter
dude and uh he was famous for um imposing order in philosophical discussions by cracking heads
and most people don't know that about him that he was this big muscle guy who would just like flex or
grab somebody and that's how he was able to impose order um amongst the other philosophers and that's why
we still to this day refer to him as plato um what everyone called him but that's what it was like
like people were half in the bag they were saying crazy shit they were getting into fights and yelling
with each other that's what a vital community is and you just dump somebody right um and that's what i
would have done to him if he hadn't uh if he hadn't taken off so bringing up plato i when i did my
law court just i just did it for fun i wanted to be a lawyer but i wasn't hard enough socrates he always
asked questions to get people to answer the answer for themselves and i just i love that about you
because you you're you that's how i believe you're acting in this space or not acting you're
i don't know what the word is you're just that you're running the space in that kind of way where
you're like let's all ask the question you're not proposing anything to anyone you're not telling
anyone they need to believe anything and that's respectful like that's a it's a really good quality
so and um well thank you i appreciate that i try to cultivate that um because what we're we're
ultimately talking about questions and we're all ultimately talking about a lot of unsubstantiated
stuff like this some we're talking at the beginning of this space about feedback related to intuitive
underground scan and project data um like that's verifiable stuff right but a lot of this is
is speculative um at best and um and so we got to kind of leave that open to question you know and
the other thing is that people get sucked into identifying with a point in an argument and it's
just a giant energy suck uh a giant drain on on everyone when people dig in and start fighting so
you just got to say like this is a question we have and i i appreciate that you've noticed that
because i do try to do that i don't know if i'm in socrates's league and according to uh alien light
um you know i'm far from it but maybe he was um and we had him here for a moment right and now
intelligence is gone uh dave too um and i haven't uh haven't communicated very much uh we were going
to do a space together a defining remote viewing space on remote viewing data related to animals and
pets and dave i want you to know that i'm still available for that anytime you are dude i know that
life took you in a different direction um and also there was some heat at that time because
um you know i uh i have a combative relationship with some of the people in the remote viewing
community even though i'm not a remote viewer ironically uh but everyone was really looking
forward to that space and um you know we we can always put it together if uh if things change
and uh you're willing to to do it at some point so i had considered just taking your your videos um from
dave's remote viewing site i don't know if he's updated in a while i haven't been back to check but
i should check was um uncontrolled remote viewing i think um on youtube and uh really there's some
good stuff there and some really profound stuff around the passing of his cat um and i'm a cat lover
myself um and he also he's done some matrix related stuff um but i you know i enjoy it you know the
the caveat is though part of what i do is i have to monitor a lot of predictive stuff um so i will
spend hours watching any remote viewers data or any astrologist data just to be able to develop an
aggregate sense of what people are are finding but you know i like dave's uh site i support it and um
i really wanted to do that i i almost went in and just like did a space about his stuff without him here
um just because it's so compelling but
i decided not to do that so at some point in the future we might do that because it's really he's
got some good videos on on the afterlife of pets and also the um the origin of of pets um that i
that really was um very moving uh hey morgan i wanted to the reason i got booted from the space
um the last time i got booted was because i was trying to send you a message saying you can dip anytime you
want um morgan's super supportive dude and uh a good friend and like he likes to hang in there but he's
also like super busy sometimes and gets super tired he might even be sleeping on the other side right now
to be honest uh is either sucking down coffee or he's he might be asleep uh i am both busy and tired but
that's okay yeah you can always bounce dude that's i i meant to tell you that before like anytime you're
in a space or something and the space is just going on longer than you anticipated like don't hesitate to
bounce i know you don't want to be rude but it's not it's not because you're tired and you got like
stuff going on right and that's understandable no it's not you and uh if basically if i'm not doing
remote viewing which requires like full attention uh if i'm doing basically anything else i have you
know either music or podcasts or spaces or something just playing in the background anyways so yeah no it's
no problem um i mean like which is to say you know if i had to to to dip to run session work i yeah i
would just simply uh either leave or i just leave it running and be in the other room or whatever but
no i'm i'm here i'm just i'm working on the computer but um yeah i'm here and by the way hey dave how you
do man nice to see you morgan can i ask you a question about remote viewing well i suppose so
well like like i think that's what i'm doing by listening to you guys but i don't know right
how do you get tested or how do i know do i you maybe you've heard me but you haven't heard me talk
tonight because i've been afraid to talk about it what like how do you know like is it the same as what
you're doing or like it's it's awful i don't like the remote viewing i prefer to time travel
but the the remote viewing is not good it's always bad things that i see and then it's not fun what but
what are your thoughts on that i because i actually have heard you speak in the past but
how did you know you were doing it and when did it start because i i don't think i've heard you tell
us that story or me anyway i've not heard right okay well it's it's a matter of
uh terminology definition semantics so remote viewing traditionally classically
is it's it refers to a very specific thing when you're remote viewing it's a deliberate thing
it's not a spontaneous thing you're operating within defined protocol and methodology it's very deliberate
um probably what you're talking about is more i mean from from kind of what i've heard is more like
spontaneous uncontrolled um so therefore it no it wouldn't fall under the traditional classification
of remote viewing it would be more like well i mean i i don't know because i don't know enough about
but i mean it would be some kind of you know astral projection or out of body or you know if if it's
like in your sleep you know some kind of dream sigh maybe or never never rule out it could just be
imagination because that's part of what defines remote viewing is you train against verifiable targets
right but you're blind to the target you don't know what it is so that kind of that guarantees that all
your uh session data you know your data and your sketches and whatnot is generated purely mentally
um and it tends to be you know like a significant like a multi-year kind of process just in the the
training stage so yeah technically what you're talking about wouldn't be categorized as remote viewing
per se um like i said i need to i need to know more about it before i could like put a label to it but um
yeah does that make sense that it totally does that's why i didn't someone told me that that's
what i must be doing because i had this i had this boyfriend and he doesn't even live in this country
and he was sleeping with another woman and obviously he was cheating on me and lying whatever
but i watched it happen and i called him out on it but i described her to a t like exactly her tattoo on
her left it was on her left arm the color of her hair that she looked basically like a heroin addict
how much she weighed what exact everything i knew her apartment number like it's when i'm connect i
feel like when i'm connected to someone soulfully or emotionally i tap in and that's where my into i
think i have more intuition but because the intuition if i actually am really invested i i freaked this
person out and they called me a witch and i'm like i i've not even been there like you live like
30 hours away i've not i've never even left my country so it that's kind of what freaked me out
and then i don't want to be called a witch either but i'm not a witch i would but it just freaked me
out because i could i just said like anyway i won't go through the whole thing but that's what scared
me because i didn't i didn't want to be right you know i don't want to be right about the visions i
see um places i see things happen those kind of things that that are happening that i that's that's
not remote viewing right or i i that's why i don't really understand what i'm seeing and how i'm getting
it all right but i don't understand what's happening because they never did this before
does that make sense i know it doesn't make sense yeah no i understand um yeah so that that would be
you know you'd call that like a spontaneous site event basically um and
yeah these kind of things are yeah on the one hand kind of relatively common on the other hand maybe
not but um no it's it's not it's not terribly unusual really it's it's part of who we are um
it's just that that part of us and you know okay maybe not everyone that the argument could be made but
um it is it is a natural function for a lot of people uh it just tends to lay dormant and you know
you kind of alluded to the possibility or probability that you know something uh maybe awoke that dormant
part of you um and it kind of that maybe latent ability just kind of manifest rather suddenly and uh
intensely is kind of what it sounds like um and i mean so yeah i can understand because
you know yeah typically i mean i'm not a terribly naturally psychic person like i do i have i have
well i mean i just i know i have like slightly above average psychic ability which is not saying a whole lot
and you know if it weren't for rv i would have zero control over that and yeah generally the strongest
psychic compressions are highly emotional you know often distressing so again that's not actually really
unusual at all um now the on the plus side and it's kind of things you can learn to exert control over
them it's just it it takes a while um but it just you know it takes just a um consistent dedication uh and
practice over time but yeah the kind of things you're talking about they can't or to be honest they
can at least in in some cases they can be shut off i know people who um you know they would they would just
just spontaneously get psychic information about things and people and tended to be kind of negative and uh
you know they chose to kind of shut that valve off uh consciously through you know just directed
willpower willpower really effort and you know kind of manifesting that reality into existence within
themselves i guess um not that not that i'm saying that's mechanistically what was actually going on but
you know in terms of maybe how to think about doing something like that effectively
it's up to you you know is it something you want to learn to work with or is it something you would
rather just shut off entirely i can i can understand you know either way
it just seems like the things i see in advance are never positive they're really traumatizing and then
it's just it's it's really not fun and and and actually it's really interesting my son
um he ended up in the hospital as well and he was sleeping and they did all the tests i thought
maybe he was schizophrenic he was talking to voices he's a baby he's like two to four to five and
he used to walk around and and we couldn't go into crowded places and he would hear voices all the
time and i said well are they telling you to do anything he said no it's just like all these people
are talking to me if we went into like a you know like a breakfast place where there's a big crowded
place whatever and um i actually got a psychic to talk to him and she said this is a gift but she said
you can tell them to go away and she said but you have to do it like you have to say
i i don't want you here i want you to leave do you know anything about that kind of stuff
because he did it and he finally could sleep through the night but it took years like it was really hard
for him um is that genetic is psychic abilities genetic do you think just a question
oh well i mean actually uh jt talked a little bit about that earlier um and i mean you know
anecdotally yeah it does seem to be that way you know i i got it from my mom i get it from my mom for
sure um and i mean well that's that's who i was talking about a moment ago you know she uh
she shut it off because she was so fed up with uh you know just kind of spontaneously knowing stuff that
on the balance of things tended to be kind of negative you know and um partly because
you know the what kind of the final straw for her was she just spontaneously got this information
about a family friend you know she just suddenly she and you know how it is you you know you don't
just think oh i have this idea no you know and she just she knew that this woman's husband was having
an affair and she you know that puts her in a dilemma and she's like well you know i have to uh
basically she wouldn't feel right not telling her you know and that's so that's what happened she told
her and it you know that ended it it was true and that uh led to the dissolution of that marriage
and you know my mom felt tremendous uh burden of guilt over that for a long time and that caused her
to just she's like no you know not enough with this and she didn't touch it again until um i guess until
i got into rv you know that's when we really started talking about this stuff like you know intensely
and i like i didn't know that story you know prior to that and she did a little bit of basic rv training
and you know she did really really good and but she didn't pursue it because
you know she didn't uh well i don't know exactly why but she chose not to but you know it just
demonstrates that yeah yeah that psychic ability it's it's still there it's right there but uh and yeah
that is to say too you know there have been
a number of times uh since then you know that was like i guess that'd be like 14
14 yeah years ago yeah that'd be about yeah 2012 yeah so yeah there have been a number of times
uh in the interim where you know she's had
um insights into things and
yeah that's really all i have to say about it do you find when you have these experiences that you're
emotionally drained after or or how do you feel
well uh
no me personally not not really um
because you know again my my natural psychic antenna is not
you know terribly above average so for me it um
personally uh you know when i was younger all this all my spontaneous psychic activity was really
kind of mundane like not actually really emotionally impactful at all
uh it would be just about just kind of pointless things totally pointless things like
uh you know when i was when i was young i don't remember what grade but i was in you know elementary
schools right right around the age when when people are like just starting to like date and
you know like not real date but you know oh my like kids with their crush oh so-and-so's my boyfriend
so-and-so's my girlfriend that kind of you know and
someone said just said something about oh so-and-so is dating so-and-so and i go i just said oh that
that'll stop on whatever date or whatever and it did you know totally pointless it just kind of
like barely registered as i was saying it just kind of spit it out and it was you know it was
totally accurate but completely meaningless you know so that's me not not like i say not really
emotionally uh impactful for me so not draining um i when i was younger i used to be empathic naturally
empathic and i found that really draining and so i shut that part of me off because i determined it did
no uh did no one any good you know tend to just kind of bring me down and really do nothing for the
other person so uh i haven't been enough of that so that's probably why i'm uh i come across as so uh
callous sometimes i don't think you come across as callous at all but you know if you want to come
across as callous we'll agree with you oh but otherwise i wouldn't say so
sometimes you sound a little worn out i don't mean that disrespectfully i mean i think that sometimes
you just sound like you might be tired at the time but not callous necessarily i don't know maybe
everyone else sees it i'll tell you one thing right like your presence in a space uh draws a lot of
people people want to they want to hear what you have to say they want to listen to you in spaces they seem to
like you a bit and uh that's not something you generally associate with a callous person so
mama 007 what's up thanks for the space hey t-bird
just about your psychic uh talk that you guys were talking about
yeah um i've got a really good psychic actually i found out after 60 years i had a brother from another
mother
okay from the psychic yep she actually she didn't tell me that specifically she asked me if i knew a jay
well we didn't have a friend or a family member or anything with jay and that's all she said like
i've got it she record we record everything so it was a year later i got a phone call from a cousin out
in nova scotia telling me to sit down because he just got notified through ancestry.com
calm they got tagged with a guy named jay that was my half brother
so i went back to the psychic i said why didn't you tell me i had a brother named jay she says we
can't do that professionally
you've got to find it for yourself it can change too much
in your future if we do things like that well that's good feedback for them though i mean i'm
sure that they were happy to hear that oh yes she's incredible and she's the one that told me i have
very high psychic abilities and it wasn't until after my dad passed away that it really kicked in
because he hasn't left my sight for a moment um but it is uh when you go to see a psychic and uh you
listen to a good one of course and you listen to the stuff they have to say that um like that right
off the bat like a jay you know you can pick any name of the in the book and i didn't know anybody
named jay whatsoever so that that blew my mind
but they are remarkable somebody that you've missed for a long time and i was really close
with my dad so it was something i really needed and it's really helped me through
just want to add to that
well thank you i appreciate that it's always nice when people come up and talk
thanks for the space j jt yeah jt j jt whatever no worries i'm i'm more of um
you know a facilitator than anything else but i appreciate it um i was gonna say yeah i got a ton of uh
of messages during this space i'm never able to really until someone else talks i'm not really
able to look at the messages because i can't multitask like that um on the phone because i'll
hit the wrong button i'll hang up i'll something will happen it always does um so i need to have
that like a level of focus when it comes to using technology that other people don't have um or don't
need to have i should say so i apologize anyone if you sent me a message and i didn't respond uh
promptly enough um usually i wait until after the the space i have some i gotta say like some people
like hey great space really interesting that to paraphrase and then some people have
some advice and i'm i'm not 100 certain on the advice so i don't know if it's advice for me or advice for
other people in the space or like a personal statement or or whatnot um i don't see any of those people
here but i didn't see them here before so that brings it around to like a lot of people when
they're in the space i don't see them on my on my device um like there's a gentleman who seems to be
quite a decorated soldier of of one kind or another i didn't look closely at his uniform we had some
advice um if anyone is here who left the advice i appreciate it i may not understand it but i will
definitely think about it um no so thank you what else we got okay dave 2 was gone uh as far as i can
see he just showed up cryptically uh silent observation i got a character in a doctor who um storyline
uh but it was good to see him he hasn't been around in a while i i uh i wasn't very happy with him last
time um because he just uh he ghosted me as opposed to showing up for the space that he said he was gonna
show up for and never said anything and didn't respond to me and then you know like six months
later i was like hey i'm just a little flaky and hey sorry about that um and i think it was probably a
response to some sort of negative opinion that someone else in the remote community had um that
was really the motivator it's never he's never said that um dave if you're out there listening and i
can't see you you're always welcome but i would like you to uh to come and do the space you said you were
going to do so that's that's pretty much the only thing i'm going to have to say whenever you show up
until you make good on your commitment um
yeah who else does anyone else have any uh anything you would like to contribute today or talk about
focus on uh comments questions concerns anything from morgan because people love asking morgan questions
and he is uh an expert on the subject remote viewing there's no question about that i think we we
demonstrate that we demonstrated that with the first hour and a half of this space where we broke down
um you know the level of of consistency consistent validation or verification of their target data
him and his team he's the project manager often usually and um may be and i think in his own
estimation stronger as a project manager even than as a remote viewer and uh obviously like you know when
you've got a bunch of viewers working on a target and the end result is a very accurate report the
project manager is probably just as important as any one viewer right or more so so um yeah he's uh
he's willing to answer questions if anyone has any i think we're winding down it's getting kind of late
like when i first started listening to spaces like a year and a half ago uh there were overnight spaces
all the time and that like that's something that's quickly gone into the past right like overnight
life in general has gone into the past like overnight restaurants and um seeing people out late at night
uh but the spaces that was sort of makes sense in the ufo x slash paranormal community right because
um most of us or a lot of us who got involved we got involved by listening to coast to coast am
um in the 80s and the aughts
uh on the overnight millions of people would listen it was sort of like um
we were a subculture or community we would walk into a store in here
uh like a convenience store and you'd hear they were listening to coast to coast am and you'd
immediately have something in common with them
and most of the people in the paranormal community now whatever community are able to tie back to those
connections um so i wish there were uh spaces uh on these subjects from like two or midnight to like
1 a.m or midnight to 3 a.m or something but there aren't people wind down go ahead mama
i got a story about a ufo site yeah uh i told t-bird about this so quite a while ago
my well we weren't married we were just kids going back and back to toronto to work on a sunday
evening um we're in ontario going down what was called taunton road uh oshawa would be pickering area
if anybody knows um ontario anyway um and this is before it was all built up very little um
houses around and there was this bridge with this farmhouse and it was just my husband and i at the
time going back and we looked over to where this farmhouse was and they had a plane out there and
the plane was has been there for years and years and years well on the other side of the house
was this god forsaken um circular huge thing that was about 200 feet off the ground
lights all the way around the bottom of it and it was lit up like a christmas tree like you'd never
believed we were the only ones on i had an old flip flash um camera there was no flashes left but i'm
taking pictures like crazy off this flip phone thing i've got or not phone sorry camera i've got and we
went back to our apartment in scarborough i ended up phoned phoning the airport to see if there was
any sightings of anything we didn't tell a whole lot of people like i don't know anybody here other
than t-bird but it is unbelievable when you see something like that uh you be careful who you tell
but it was incredible absolutely incredible and no the pictures did not turn out at all
i've actually never seen i've seen a couple of like random silver things in the sky but i i don't have
much experience with uh actual ufo sightings or that is the first and only time we ever seen something
like that ever and that was in 1982
um yeah i'm i'm in ontario actually and um yeah there's some stories um you know the oshawa area
then right yeah i'm not over that way no no no but you know taunton road it was right on taunton road
okay yeah oh yeah just north of the 401 oh my gosh yeah yeah sure yep there yeah there's uh
there's some and you said 1982 yeah um 1982 it was um uh october just don't know it wasn't that late
just a minute it'd be around mid-september 1982 sure yeah i should have written down the date i probably
do have it written down in one of my little old diaries i had i've never brought back out but oh
my gosh like you don't unless people talk about the subject you don't bring it up because people think
you've i've already got a tinfoil hat i've been wearing it very well yeah no well it no it's true okay
uh so um my dad um so you know i i i'm from rural uh rural ontario you know i'm about three hours uh
west of toronto like gta basically okay rural i grew up on dairy farm and
uh so a friend a friend of my dad's when they were kids so this is this is back in like the 60s um
so he was uh my dad's friend was i don't know like seven or eight and then he had a younger sister
that was like you know three or four years younger and they were just you know they were hanging out on
i think it was you know a weekend sunday afternoon or whatever and they were just kind of walking around
in the forest and there's a clearing and they said you know plain as day there was a
rather typical kind of silvery disc ufo type thing physical there right in front of their eyes
um and you know that guy he's only told that story probably a few times in his life
uh he told he told it to you know my dad and their friends when they were kids
and then he really never talked about it again until you know my dad said he did decades later
he bumped into him somewhere in town and and he just he said hey you remember that
story you told us it's like that was that was for real and he go oh yeah no oh yeah that was real
but you know other than that really he never never oh yeah i don't bring it up at all yeah
unless somebody's talking about it and somebody else has seen it it's like okay you know now now you can
talk because they've witnessed it you know what i mean otherwise people say yeah okay lady
yeah yeah something you don't forget that that's for sure no and it's you know just that um kind of
well whatever factor it is you know it's ultimately you know whether it's a the bizarre port the
bizarre point of it though morgan we were the only ones on the road and it was all farmland at that
time like i said it wasn't built up it was whitney uh westney road um in whitney or whitby was just
getting built up at that time they were just starting to do the road and stuff but it was all farmland
so i mean it was plain as day it was just wow yeah it well it's something else and but you know
it makes you think probably these things are more common than than most people think because they're you
know there are probably you know for every person that uh speaks about it even even rarely but you
know you you have spoken about it there are probably people who you know they'll go to their grave never
telling us talking about it you know yeah exactly yeah oh my grandson that's 15 he is all about um
area 51 he wants to go and he wants to do the tour and he's all into this stuff
why did you tell him oh god yeah oh yeah when we told him about it same with the ghost that we had
at the old house it was an 18th century house and i never seen them my husband had a visual and my son
did and my son's best friend did but i got all the electrical stuff happened to me and it was a psychic
that i had before the one that told me about jay um she had told me if it was something that was
bothering us and it never it was nothing ever that was demonic or anything it was just like
the kettle would go on just in time for it we're ready for a tea or coffee and i had friends over
witnessing this a manual kettle you know um i'd put something in the oven go and pick up my husband
from work i come home the oven's been turned off it's still warm i turned it on but it's been turned
off tv and everything else was turned off you know and i'd have to write these things down just to get
him to to believe me and then he seen a lady and didn't tell me for about two years so it was like
wow but the psychic had told me if it's something that you don't want it in the house light a green
candle and tell it to go to the light and they will and you know what it it worked like a charm it worked
the only thing is about three months later we started missing it because we had nothing to talk
about okay that's funny yeah it is yeah but it was uh i'd love to hear from the people that own the
house before us and he's passed away and i don't know where she lives now and whether or not they ever
got it because this was an older man and the gentleman that lived beside us was his wife it was his
original home like they didn't even have an outdoor bathroom that's how old this house wasn't re-renovated
so but it was quite it was quite a story too
all that um yeah and and you know again i'll i'll bet that kind of experience is more
common than a lot of people would think because oh is it yeah is it ever
like i mean people are getting getting these balls i don't even know what they're called
um and you can literally talk to spirits and stuff i do enough of that in my garage
i don't need a ball to help me so um one of the things we're going to talk about next saturday when
we talk about i think it's gonna be five but i haven't chose the number yet i haven't worked it out
the things that remote viewers don't like to talk about now i don't know if morgan will be part of that
discussion now he's pretty bold on many subjects but there are a couple that in my experience every
remote viewer only talks about in whispers and one of them is a certain type of extraterrestrial
encounter or remote viewing session i'm gonna just leave it there until next week but there is
there's at least one jt i've never heard i've never heard of a remote viewer it's the first time i've
ever heard of that term so i'm gonna google that that's what morgan is he's remote viewer yep okay
but there's this one particular type of um it's a it's a a structured psychic protocol designed by the
u.s government in the um from the 70s to the 90s uh but there is one particular type of um
uh extraterrestrial um encounter that um is is seen far more often than anyone would suspect
because people only speak about it in whispers and that is one of at least five things
the grays no no but i'm not going to talk about it because it's next week morgan already knows but um
we'll talk about it next week next saturday because that's i need a subject for next saturday's
space i just wanted it's a teaser it's a curiosity hook for anyone who's still here who who might be
interested in coming next saturday i'm going to say like we've you know i've got there are some
definitely some things that that that people only speak about in whispers and we're going to talk about
them out loud uh here on saturday and thursday we're doing 200 griefers which is i think i
explained earlier drawing connections between um the concept of like uh fallen angels watchers
uh nephilim and the concept of living in a simulation and how those two might go together
um yeah so i just wanted to leave that curiosity hook for everyone
um if anyone else says if you if you um have more stuff you more stories you want to
relate or whatever um i'm just getting close to the point of wrapping it up but i'm not trying to
quiet or silence anyone i just uh wanted to get that in before i conk out
i'm getting kind of tired well thanks again for the space buddy i really appreciate it yeah
no thanks for coming up and talking i'm sorry that uh that i'm not getting my second wind right now
but um you can feel free to to talk about whatever you'd like i just at some point i'm gonna conk out
um
the the see i'm having trouble putting thoughts together uh t bird morgan um any other
insights thoughts comments questions concerns um stories no not really i'm gonna have to jet here in a few
minutes yeah but um yeah i think uh probably margie and i'll run another rv space great uh i don't know
when probably next week either late next week or maybe next weekend um i'll book it in the next few
days and and post about it uh hopefully you know at least like four or five days ahead of time
for change that'd be great and your websites are oh i guess intuitive underground.com
or remoteviewtraining.com cool and uh dave too who silently observed us a little bit earlier his
website is uncontrolled remote viewing or his youtube channel is uncontrolled remote viewing
i do not have a youtube channel um but i'm hoping to have a podcast soon let's see
if that comes together um you know i'm dropping the seed out there into the universe uh looking for
a co-host so oh hey let me mention i think yeah i did mention this to you before but
you know what you should do you really should take um segments out of out of your spaces
and upload them to other platforms you know by topic because
uh i think you reach a lot more people that way and there's and there's a lot of really good stuff in
there um and you know it's like it's long spaces are good but the the downside to them is now i guess
on the one hand you kind of get the primary topics out of the way at the beginning but
there could there could be you know some people might see you know well what was the other week
there's like a seven hour space some people might see that and it's like that's daunting and they might
not even start so i really do think that if you chopped up um you know at least some of the more
important what you think are the more important segments and and uploaded them as you know either clips
like long or medium length clips or even shorts in some cases you know like the
the 10 to 30 second or even like minute long uh little you know more digestible
chunks i guess i don't know anyways something you should i think it's a great uh suggestion
the issue that i have with that i mean you know it's a great suggestion but the problem is
uh coming from my level of text technological expertise that's like talking about some iron man
robert downey jr type shit right there um taking the spaces out chopping off into sections and recording
that other um right i pretty much run the spaces and will run the podcast like i run the spaces uh
completely unedited um stream of consciousness because any other level of technology is is beyond me
that having been said it's possible at some point that i will connect with someone with that that level
of technological aptitude who will take care of that but um if you gave me a thousand dollars to do that
tonight i couldn't do it well that doesn't mean i won't ever be able to do it but it's it's tonight
it's it's far beyond uh you know it's kind of funny i'm actually i'm supposed to talk to somebody next week
about it's uh well among other things but that basically so uh if i can if i can glean anything
useful and compress it into um something uh that you'll understand because i'm equally uh i'm really
not up to date with you know tech and uh yeah is it aaron because aaron was our technological advisor and
then he uh he added off to the hills no yeah he was he was our tech guy he was the guy who would answer
my questions and uh and he's no longer available for whatever reason i hope he's he's doing well um
i don't think he's he's blocked me because uh i'm not able to see his
page so i think his his x page is no longer active um i hope he comes back i hope he's doing well i hope
he's doing okay uh it was always good to have him in the spaces but now we're on more technologically
speaking i agree with morgan i didn't see your space until like you guys had already been going
but when i see more i see i didn't know you jt but i was already following morgan but i i only found him
maybe a couple hours later for some reason and uh i missed the very beginning but i mean the talk you
spoke but and let's face it we all have add or adhd at this point we're all like did it right no one has
time i i don't understand people who are like i heard your space last night and you listen to it
for five hours like i don't go back and listen to spaces that's personally me i don't have the time
to not that i i do have the time to i just don't have the attention span but in the moment if i'm intrigued
like i think a lot of us are um when you hit a topic you're just like oh yeah that turns me on i
want to listen to that and tonight i would point to uh your information for me personally when i
finally came to the space was the crank and like the crank radio and with the short rave your your
intellect on that um there was there was quite a few points actually i can't even come up with all
them right now well thank you thank you for the uh feedback i appreciate it yeah i know but it's
really important i think people need to know that information if we're going to prepare them from what
we see what's going to happen and like i said i didn't i don't know in my remote view or am i not
why do i see things that i don't see and different than other people i i i can't call myself anything
right now except for obscure but i i learned so much tonight but yeah that was huge there was a bunch
of stuff tonight like little points that might take one or two minutes with your explanation that
are that you could just put maybe on your i know clipping i'm not i'm old i'm old too so i'm not i'm
not techie but if you could clip that and put that on your page and pin it to your profile then it would
show up because i follow you then i can like share it to other people that's all i know how to do but
that's the stuff i want to share is the stuff that you because you have the technological information
you just like rhymed it off exactly what i asked and it's really important the same with morgan that
like i anyway that's all i wanted to say i agree with morgan that'd be good if you could
yeah yeah thank you very much for the space thank you guys if no one has anything else i'm going to wrap
up the space uh it's a 15 15 oh god 15 second um period of silence for some people at the end of the
space because some of us are on the delay and others are not uh and then the space will end i
appreciate everyone coming uh i t bird thank you um uh mama sadie shane melissa iru kanji and i apologize for
having difficulty pronouncing names i often do sinning that's great to see you and our one anonymous
listener uh anonymous listeners are always welcomed and encouraged uh morgan thank you very much for uh
helping out tonight and um you know you're you're welcome uh thursday and saturday but you don't have
to come and you can always divide anytime you want and i know that um you know next saturday i'll be
talking about some of the things that that people only whisper about so it would be more than
understandable if you if you choose not to uh join in for that reason um but you're you're definitely
welcome all right everyone thank you very much and have a good night uh yeah thanks jt